[inaudible] were fucking live.
I was just about to take a sip of coffee,
but this shit is way more important.
We're here with Jim Florentine, hilarious,
standup comedian and Trans Racial Pioneer.
You were doing that.
You were pushing the Trans Racial movement
like about two or three decades ago,
right? I was, you know, and um, you
know, it was living with Jim Norton is,
I've seen a lot. That video,
there's a video of you guys.
Was it you two living together where you
had the fucking black mold? Oh my God.
When you move the picture and
you see the mold of the wall,
people fucking die from that shit. Like
the amount of mold you guys had. I know.
I had it in my bedroom and I would just,
I put tinfoil on the walls to
cover it around by the bed.
It was all the way up coming up,
crawling up the walls.
I just put tinfoil on mine. It should
be fine. It's so fucking crazy.
Who made that video?
It was somebody from Oni show
came over and did the cribs. God.
He like, people get really sick from
that shit. Right. I know. I don't know.
Understand how we didn't get sick
cause we had it for like a year.
We're paying $800 for three for three
bedroom right outside of New York City and
the Jersey side and
splitting it three ways.
I had a girl if I'm
living me at the time too,
so we were paying like two 66 a
month. Wow. That's pretty sweet.
And we weren't making any money so we
figured we'll move right next to New York
City and here's the video
it's going on behind you.
Did you test it and see if he
had anything from living there?
Well fuck now Tom,
like he's had a evacuated,
his whole house Tom like is they
had a terrace walls down. They,
they have to like,
I guess they treat the mold to kill it.
They got a tear all your walls down and
they get to do these like tests of the
air to make sure there's not spores
that are flying around in the air.
I mean it's a real infestation.
It's fucked. I know we didn't,
we didn't even do like a mold.
We didn't even look it up to
find out if it was toxic. It's a,
I'm pretty sure it's not good.
Like this is sick.
It's like it's dripping down
the side of this painting now.
They moved this painting.
It was,
we went to a garage sale around the
corner to buy more paintings just to cover
up the mold that's got can now.
Oh, it's super bad for you. That's
absolutely soup. You know what?
My Damn Marino Jersey and hang it up,
but you got to think that just
the sheer air that's in that room,
that'd be filled with spores and shit.
Right. I think that's very, very poisoned.
It's like you probably have some
kind of fucked up shit from that. No,
I bet he's fine now.
You don't,
but I bet back then you're
probably suffering from
just a lot of stress on your
lungs. What am I a doctor? Was Your
Voice Really High Pitch? Was it like,
know he's been like this? Yeah, it's
always had the voice that didn't work,
but when you're fucking young
and poor and you're a comic,
that is the way to go to 66 a month.
Huh?
The lower your bills are like for
comics it's like the whole thing in the
beginning is you got to get through the
spot where you don't make any money,
figure out how to do it and
then it start making money.
Start getting road gigs and start.
But area where you just like,
it's so important to fucking save as
much money as possible. Yeah, we were,
we were living like an hour
south of the city in Jersey.
Me and no art and then we figured we
needed to get close because we've gone in
there like four or five nights
a week trying to get into clubs.
I moved in with it.
I didn't even like this girl.
I just wanted to pay a third at a rent.
I really didn't even like her that much.
I'm like, look, we can cut this
in threes. That's hilarious.
Look at Jim off fresh faced like
cause I will add like a little boy.
Oh your bathroom g suite.
Merciful Christ.
I had a shit hole of an
apartment in new Rochelle. Ooh.
It's actually could have been a lot worse.
This is like just mostly families
and shit in the neighborhood,
but that was the same thing as the
cheapest place that I could get that had a
place to park cause I had
to do a lot of road gigs. I,
I did city gigs like in in New York City,
but at a certain point in time I was like,
fuck man,
he sits are only like 10 15 minutes long.
You've got to travel all over to do
them and they don't pay any money.
I could just go to Connecticut and
make 150 bucks tonight. You know,
I could go to long island and make
150 bucks. I think that's real money.
I think that's when I first met you is
Bob Levy and his wife had all these like
eggs, these one nighters that pay
like 150 bucks, 200 his wife was hot.
God Good Lord was insane. She was one
of those like what happened there?
Relationships. First of all, Bob
is hilarious. Chicks love like,
he's so funny. Like if you
ever hung around with Bob
Levy, do you know Bob Leave?
You know, haven't hung out with this
fucking hilarious. That dude's hilarious.
He was at a, I watched um, uh,
Artie Lange headline in Vegas ones at
the Luxor is me and Joey and Eddie Bravo
went cause we were there
for the UFC and um,
he went up and he was doing some shit
where he was having girls eat his asshole.
They put blue cheese on his ass and he
was describing why he couldn't do that
anymore because of lawsuits or whatever.
But he would put blue cheese and girls
asses and eat it on stage right on stage
right out of her ass. Wouldn't
do it. But I don't know.
He was a famous comedian.
I mean Bob believe he's like a nationally
known comedian and he's doing these
girls from the audience, from the audit
guys. White guy would go with his wife,
go up there, come on and let him
eat blue cheese out of your ass.
What's the big deal? I'm like,
it's so crazy. It's so crazy,
but he's just a funny fuck.
Like people were heckling him
and he was just torturing them.
Bob's been around forever.
He's, he's an old pace.
One of the best night club comics
out there. Oh, pro old pills.
Every time knows how to do it.
He's just a funny guys just been
around and he's a good dude too.
But God damn did he have a hot wife?
I'll believe them. She still hot.
I should came to my Cheryl. I'm
sure she hears still hot. Crushing.
It was insane how hot she was. Like
Bob, there's no, you don't deserve that.
Has that happened in California? Would
kind of make sense if Bob was on a sitcom.
If I was on a Sitcom and
she lived in California,
like girls like her I think
are more common in California,
but in Jersey she fucking Christ like
they didn't even have the name of a number
for that.
She wasn't even a 10 he had to like,
you gotta go like,
it's like a 10 plus executive class 10
and she hung in there for like three
years and then she just couldn't
take it out. They were booking gigs.
I did a bunch of their gigs. Yeah.
That's when I originally met Yo.
Cause he'd do a bunch of one
night or such a good dude. Yeah.
Always been a good dude. Funny, crazy
fuck would. Yeah, he would. But,
and you don't want,
he's had,
he had to stop being blue cheese at a
girl's acids can because he was going
through a divorce and his ex wife,
the second wife,
the lawyers will use in the footage on
youtube against him in court to tell the
audience, look, I gotta stop eating blue
jeans. And they would bow. He goes, look,
their shits on Youtube. I'm trying
to get custody of my son. Oh my God.
It's just like specific dressing.
What about thousand dollars?
No blue cheese and nothing like book.
This girl is there.
He puts blue cheese on her ass and he
eats it onstage. What a lucky guy. Oh,
he's a savage and he holds on to,
he doesn't let go. Let go. Hold on.
I know they're trying to
run away and he's, he's a
fucking savage. He's a savage.
He's the get that girl's
ass hoe. Jesus Christ. Wow.
Blue Cheese in Wildwood.
I mean it's kind of like a
cultural legend thing. You know?
Like when, when I, by the way, when
I first heard that he was doing,
it wasn't even remotely remotely
surprised. I was like, oh,
Bob believes he's doing that all
right. Yeah, it's fucking crazy.
They'd tell it like if somebody told
me that Greg Fitzsimmons started eating
blue cheese at a girl's
acids, I'd be like, Whoa,
what the fuck happened at Greg
Greg One south. He went crazy.
Briggs gone crazy. But when,
when I heard it was Bob Levy,
it was like totally acceptable.
Like if you know him,
like something like that's click
completely acceptable. Like, Oh yeah,
that's probably what he does.
I'm the first time he did it,
we would just get got cancels who were
just hanging out like holiday inn in the,
in the room where the comedy
is supposed to be in some,
some girl was there and we were drinking
with her and we somehow we got her to
go, hey, we'll get,
we'll get mushed it up like $37 if he
can eat blue cheese out of your ass,
cause wheat and wings. And Bob said, I
want to just blue cheese out of your ass.
And I go, how much would you do
it? She goes, I don't know what,
I've got 37 she goes,
okay fine.
And he blokes are just in front of
like four people and maybe he's like,
I got to close with that.
I
got it right. I go, got worked
at, please join US friends.
I don't know if that's going to
work on stage. Oh my God. I kind of,
well kind of a fucking animal.
What kind of fucking animal offers?
He drilled $37 to eat blue cheese that
her ass. And then after he's, as it says,
I got to close with that.
Oh my God,
I'm fucking crying.
Those are the beautiful people that
you meet in standup comedy. You know,
this is the only meet those people
in stand up comedy. You just don't,
they don't exist in other professions or
like extreme Elvis. I've met that guy.
If he this crazy, his show was amazing.
I don't think he does that anymore. Yeah,
I don't think he does. It was a
fucking amazing show. Extreme Elvis is,
this guy's an Elvis impersonator
and he takes his clothes off and he
pisses in this girl's mouth. It's like,
it's fucking crazy. He gets totally naked.
Yeah. And they're really good musicians.
Like Penn Jillette to
pendula tell them about me,
but I don't know who told who about doubt.
But he and I talked and he wound up
hiring the guy to do like a party at his
house and pens like strict and
like no drugs, no this, no that.
So you had to do it sober cause extreme
Elvis would do all shows completely
fucked up. Like drink a gallon
of fucking whiskey on states.
That's him right there. Holy Shit. Yeah
Dude. I mean you ain't seen nothing yet.
There was,
I wrote a whole blog about it.
I wrote a whole blog
about it a long time ago.
Like way back in 2003 because he was
amazing. This show was amazing. He Ha,
he goes, who owns showing
through change purse? This girl,
the girl next to him goes, hi, do
I do, he just pisses in her mouth.
She's lying there. She's
topless. She's hot by the way.
And she's talented and she can play,
you know, I forget what, what she did,
whether she sang or she played guitar,
I forget when instrument,
but I remember overall
was a very good shot.
They're very talented on top
of the fact it was insane.
You'd be pissing in this girl's mouth
and some guy like in from the audience,
like someone or was a girl.
Some girl tried to stick
like a beer bottle up his
ass cause he gets cut totally
naked.
So some girl comes up behind him and it
started sticking this beer bottle up his
ass and he grabs her hand and starts
putting it the right in the right hole and
then she panics and she runs away.
Like he was helping her shoved
this beer bottle up his ass. Holy.
You don't want to do that. It's just
like fuck this and the girl just leaves.
But it is, it was a fucking crazy
show. Just see what Jamie just put up.
It was a pool cue. Uh, I'm not surprised,
but I'm also not surprised
that he doesn't do it anymore.
If he was doing these kinds of things on
a regular basis because that's fucking
dangerous or your asshole.
You can't just have random
strangers stick stuff up your ass.
They won't be so kind. Yeah. That
sounds like GG Allen. What did you just,
she would just take a shit on stage is
just throwing up the audience before it.
If the first song, I'm telling you
though, this dude is really good.
Like as a musician, he was
really fucking good. That's it.
That was the craziest
thing about the show.
It was not just that it was this freak
show. He's doing the freak show thing,
but he's a fucking talented musician.
Like he does a wicked Elvis,
like he's doing suspicious minds and
the whole audience was singing along.
We're caught in a trap to that,
to the two.
I can't walk out well like the whole
crowd was going because I love you too.
And these guys get,
he's got his dick out.
He's fucking naked on stage is pissed
and a girl's mouth and they're singing
suspicious minds.
I mean it's a fucking show,
not a girl that he pissed at her mouth
as she ended a band and she's good.
I forget what she did. Fuck,
I wish I could remember,
cause it was like 12 years ago.
We saw it in like 2003
so every night he would piss in her mouth.
I don't know how many times they did
shows, but I talked to him briefly.
He was telling him,
telling me all these different times he's
been arrested at all different times.
They wouldn't give his money
because a lot of times the clubs,
they don't know what the
fuck he's going to do.
And then also this guy's getting tick out.
He's pissing girl's mouths and shit.
I don't think they understand the show.
I just really don't think they
understand what they're signing up for.
So these like rock venues would have him
come in there and then they get fucking
mad.
I don't even want to beat him up.
I'm didn't hire him at the
end of the night. Shit,
I gotta find out this guy's still
around. I want to see the show. I hope.
I hope he is. I hope, but I hope
he takes better care of himself.
Like you can't, you can't just drink a
bottle of whiskey every night and do this.
It's just I can't, I don't, can't imagine
how he could do this show all the time.
This is a fucking super
dangerous show for your body.
He's got a bunch of chickens picking.
He's lying down.
They're tied up and they put green all
over his cock and he's got a bunch of
chickens that they put on top of the
sheet and they're pecking at the grain.
It's right over his dick. This is so
fucking bizarre. Is that guy over there?
Exactly. Exactly. Who's that guy?
Oh Shit. He's out of his mind.
It's like Ari Schick fear.
Last time I saw him it was a,
I was going into the um, Paul
Provenza greenroom showed
you ever do that show? No.
I know we talked about but didn't get a
chance to ask him what or not he's doing
it again.
Fuck that guy was good though.
Here's at the comedy store.
I probably like two years ago,
any of him singing because what's that?
We'll see if you can find one word.
There's actual singing because the
crazy thing is that he's really fucking
really talented. It was a
great show though. It was
very few shows where you go,
fuck yeah, absolutely.
Out of there and you go,
I just guess I saw the king pissing this
chick's mouth and then have the whole
audience singing along to a song.
It was awesome. That's great.
Is there anything like that right
now that's, that's big. That's,
it's hard to do something like that.
It's could because you know this
was 2003 so the Internet was around.
It wasn't around like as around
now it's not the same thing.
Like you would go to jail.
You're not allowed to do that.
You can't just pull your
dick out and insurance and
everything. Yeah. Everything.
Yeah. No one's going to take
a chance anymore. By the way.
What the fuck is wrong with the world
where a guy can't piss in the girl's mouth
on stage like that? You can't prove to
me that the sound art because it is art.
Okay. If you can make a
show that's that fucked up.
You got a guy who's Elvis.
He's, he sings really good.
He's kind of fucking talented band
with them. Oh, one of his band members,
she takes off her clothes,
her tits, her out,
and he pisses in her mouth and
it's Dick's about that pig.
It's the whole thing is ridiculous
because it is a goddamn ridiculous show.
And the piston in her mouth make the
show better, like as an artistic piece.
Absolutely. For real because it was
just more surreal and more fucked up.
But how is that an illegal Goddamn
Communists, Jim Florentine?
I don't understand that. Hey, he'd
have to do like backyard shows
that this point.
This
what year is this?
is that what it's headed?
Well,
there was a lot of this at the shows too.
A lot of fucking screaming
and people couldn't believe.
What is he doing?
I used to have an extreme Elvis tee shirt.
I think I lost it somewhere. I think
I left it in a hotel room somewhere.
Hate fucker. Hate that. Ex
girlfriends taking your shirts.
Tell rooms because Elvis baby thickness.
He's doing that song.
Black Sabbath by black Sabbath.
Yeah,
Elvis don't Jose.
It's beautiful.
Think I think
the folks at home get the point,
but go check him out if he's still there.
I kind of around any mortar lead
singer died about a year ago.
They're going to great stage show.
Was it like that? Just shoot.
She is on the crowd and
stuff like that. Yeah. Yeah.
There was a lot of special effects,
like things coming out of chest and stuff.
There was a girl in the band.
She gave birth to a baby and the baby
came out and they put it right in the wood
chipper and the blog on all over the
audience. I was like 23 years old.
I'm like to stick right as thing that
I've ever seen in my life. I wish.
That's one thing I wish I got to see.
I never got to see a guar concert.
Oh my God. They threw a fake
baby, came right out of our gate.
I think you're still doing shows
with all the members and stuff,
but gray band always, always went to
see it. I'm like, oh my God. How did,
how did they not go to jail for that?
How did they not get like
there was some protest,
some family advocacy group or anything?
I mean,
I would think that someone would protest.
You put a fake baby in a woods shepherd
as a part of your act. They would do it,
whatever president.
They would cut his head off.
That was whoever was president at the
time. They cut his head off on stage.
You can still do that though.
Kenyon. Yeah, they still do.
It was to just do it with doing it up.
I saw him two years ago.
They were doing with Obama. Just
head off. Yeah. Jesus Christ.
I would think that the secret service who
come get you if you did some shit like
that. Yeah. That's why I like rules.
I thought you weren't even allowed to
say like, I want to kill the president.
He didn't let me finish.
I've John the juice.
You're never something like that is why
I would always say something at the end.
Why not what George Bush did it for
Bush circuit city. Look at this.
Look at the outfit. This fucking
guy's got on. Does he have a fake?
Is that what I saw?
Got a giant fake ticket. I'm going
to fuck them. It's a fist. Oh,
what is his dick? What
does, oh my God, yes.
In the plugs in the courts right now.
Right off. And it squirts in the crowd.
Oh my God,
this is so ridiculous.
It's kind of like for something for
kids when you go to like Disneyland or
Universal Studios, like one of
those shows, but for adults,
do you think they know about this?
Oh,
you showed a deal cause they were doing
President Bush when he was in office.
So whoever,
whatever president is.
So she seems like you could go
to jail for this, doesn't it?
It kind of falls into cheesy horror movie
kind of category. I'll blow for sure.
But I mean it brings up, it brings up
an interesting conversation about, um,
making fun of things and
what you shouldn't, shouldn't
be able to make fun of.
Cause that Charlie Hebdo
thing that happened, you know,
that's uh, you, you know,
you don't know what that is in France,
the people that ran this magazine has
this magazine that did a lot of satire
drawings of Muhammad and, and
these dudes showed up, um, and,
and fucking gun them all
down. Killed everybody. Right?
And they killed the dude's.
They had a man hunt for him and
he's to a radical Muslim dudes.
But um, that was just, you know, drawing,
drawing pictures, which everybody's like,
oh, well that's fucked up. You
can't do that. You just can't do,
you can't kill people for drawn a picture.
But we do have certain things
you're not allowed to do. Like you,
you literally can't say,
I want to kill Mr President.
You can't say that.
He couldn't say his name if you
said that, if you said, I want to,
I want to kill that guy, I want to kill
the president. Like that's illegal,
like you think would literally
lock you up for that.
Which is weird because he's like, you
know, that's a kind of a figure of speech.
You know, like people say that all
the time, oh, I want to kill that guy.
Fucking hate him.
I mean like you,
you like if there's a guy in
a movie that sucks like these,
like you don't like him as
an actor, you might say, oh,
I want to kill that fucking guy. You
don't mean it. Right. But is that illegal?
Like if you say that like the president
has some stupid thing that he vetoes or
something that people don't agree with.
If you said that it's a common figure of
speech was you said that and he did it
publicly,
they can fucking take you in.
You had a secret service
at your house the next day.
Ted Nugent said something a
couple of years ago about Obama,
not say I want to kill him,
but he said something,
I forget what the quote was in the secret
service was at his house the next day.
I think he was saying something
to the like, he's just like,
if Obama gets arrested, he
might wind up in jail. Yeah,
we're all gonna be dead and in
jail or something like that.
So it wasn't even a direct,
not the president.
I think he was saying that
like he might wind up in jail,
that Nugent might wind up in jail.
Something like that crying, you know,
it could be seen as implying that he would
do something cause he, but it's weird,
you know to do, I'm just going
to kill the president and stop,
you know he's doing a hunting show,
likes playing guitar.
It's not going to kill the president.
And then Ted Horse,
he's like with the secret service can,
they are fans of mine.
And I put like little concert with,
I gave him all my,
my latest CD is that I was going to take
him out back and the shooting range,
but they didn't want to do it.
Have you ever seen him in the helicopters
shooting pigs? No. You gotta see it.
You gotta see it. It's one of the
greatest things the world has ever known.
Ted Nugent in a helicopter shooting wild
pigs with a machine gun just tucked on
punk picked up on,
it's the fucking craziest thing flying
around in Texas in a fucking helicopter.
Him and his dude,
they call him pig man.
So pig man and Ted Nugent and they're
circling around these giant packs of pigs
and just lighten them up. It's
fucked up. And was he it? Yeah,
he'll play it. I love new. Is this it?
This is just talking
about the devastation.
There's like a whole graphic before the
video that shows this Devin what these
wild pigs do in Texas because they are
absolutely devastating to the farms down
there. They're not out of
control. There's so many of them,
millions of wild pigs in Texas alone.
I mean it's a fucking infestation.
But like as you see when you're
circling over in the helicopter,
you're talking about a huge area.
I mean Texas has goddamn an enormous
and these things are impossible to
eradicate cause they're smart.
So once they get together and they're
fucking shooting these things out of
helicopters and it's fucking madness.
You can shoot as many as you want all
day long and you shoot them at night.
There's no rules. You just
shoot him. I mean it's like,
look at this. This is crazy.
Awful.
It's awful.
Well wouldn't be awful if you were hungry
and you wanted a pig or if it was your
farm. The problem is if it's your farm,
like fuck man, like what is a farm?
Then, you know, I, if they
become a threat to people,
that's one thing, but it is
really weird that you could just,
just because their cost, they cost money.
Like they're chewing up people's food,
but their animals, you know, like
that's what they kind of do. Yeah.
It's like they have to manage them,
but you have to figure out a
way to manage the population.
But it seems like they can't, it seems
like there's just too many of them.
They just have to kill him. But doing
it that way just seems kind of fucked.
It's like, it seems that we can put him
to sleep in [inaudible] bed or something.
Like make it to the latest thing where
we bless these pigs instead of shooting
them with a machine gun out of a
helicopter. It's just, you know, no,
I don't know.
I mean look at cats and dogs.
Like we, we put cats and dogs to sleep
or we try to do something for them,
but like, like animals that we need to
get over that we're overpopulated with,
you know, we shouldn't be really allowed
to heal. Just like, I don't know,
torture or shoot with machine
gun out of a helicopter.
I think they're just doing it because
it's one of the only ways it's effective I
think on the ground.
You can't get to them.
Doing it from a helicopter is like one
of the best ways to do it because they're
too smart. If you're on the ground,
you try to get near him. They run away,
they smelled
things,
they hear things they don't see very good,
but they can hear very well and
they smell anything. They just bolt.
What about poisoning?
It can poison them cause then you
poison a bunch of other shit too and you
poison the environment and you poisoned
the things that eat the things he
poisoned. If you poison a pig and the
pig gets eaten by a mountain lion,
a mountain lion gets poisoned too.
And the mountain lion could dive
from the same disease or the same um,
poison that you can't have that pig meat.
Either pygmy goes bad.
They just kind of figured out a
way to keep them from, you know,
that's one of the best
ways it's fucked up.
But it's one of the best ways to kill him.
So those helicopter things,
cause they could do it and they can get
a hundred of them, 200 of them in a day.
They got 450 in one day on that pig
man show. Pigs are so smart though.
It sucks. I don't like when smarter,
you know, I hear you. It's fuck yeah,
you're right. You're right.
There's, they're smart.
But there is such a big difference
between smart animals and smart people.
There's a giant fucking difference.
And I wonder what the,
the variable of like being wild is.
Cause like pigs,
if you're around pigs and they're,
um, they're a domesticated,
they're sweet.
They're really sweet little animals
to come over and hang with you.
They're pretty cool but are domesticated.
So it means their experiences,
none of their experience
has been devastating.
They haven't seen their mother getting
killed by a wild mountain lion or
something like that. They haven't seen
their brother getting eaten by a bear.
You know, they're, they're
not living in the wild,
just running away from shit all the time.
Like a wild pig is they're constantly
fed and taken care of so they have like,
it's sorta like people, you know, people,
if you leave people in a wild state,
like people,
even to this day,
there's places in the world where people
live a far scarier life than we could
ever imagine.
Like every day you're dealing with
violence and chaos and danger.
Those people are, there couldn't
be a wilder style of human being.
Then we are, you know, and I think
that's what's going on with these pigs.
It's like it's kind of fucked that
you can eat something that also,
if the circumstances were better,
it could be your buddy kind of had on
that pig and it would be awesome. Yeah.
Years, there's, there's
definitely something to that
because it's all about their,
their experiences. If they're growing
up in a cage and you just, I mean,
we don't even understand their behavior
because the behavior that we have of
pigs is almost all of it is behavior of
things that are locked up. You know, the,
the actual wild behavior of him, they're
super hard to watch. You've got to,
it's hard to get close to them.
You know if tried tagging them and
releasing them and all that a fucking
nightmare.
They're clever fuckers.
It's almost like it could take a shitload
of pigs and put it in some kind of
like spinning like a windmill type things
and that we can make them ahead make
energy for us and instead or
something like that. Right,
like give him food in a giant hamster
wheel and as they go and chase after the
food. Yeah, but you
have to make that food.
It's like it takes energy to make the
food that's going to give them energy.
Like logically it wouldn't make sense
unless you have like a super good,
very efficient system or like each spin
was worth like hundreds of kilowatts and
right.
The windmill was like five miles long and
it's just rows and rows of pigs to it.
How much food would you
have to give those fucks?
You don't have to give him anything
but be fake food and then they die,
smelled good,
cut them up and let them eat their food.
I thought about this at all.
They eat the row in front of them and
they're done in by row each roads like a
week, so they die in the ones in
front of fuck, eat, shut the fuck up.
You know,
they say that's one of the best,
like that movie snatch that they'd say
that really is one of the best ways to
get rid of a body man.
Some guy who was a pig farmer in,
I think it was British Columbia was also
a serial killer and he would throw the
bodies into the pig sty and the pigs
would just destroy them, eat everything.
They eat, everything. It's shit
out the teeth. That's about it.
Everything else gets done. They chew
through the bones, everything. Wow. Yeah,
they're monsters.
It's crazy.
This girl I met recently,
she collects teeth and like all
the teeth I know on the teeth,
all the teeth have a story like this is
my friend Jeff's tooth or this is the
girl's tooth that I met
on a subway or whatever,
and she says she likes to throw them
in her bed and sleep with it. The tea.
So when she wakes up, but it looks
like teeth marks all over her body.
Let me open your mouth if you're
missing any Christ. And uh,
when do you guys getting married
and yet you still got your wisdom
teeth? Yeah, I know I got rid of, well,
I've got it right. Yeah. Cause she'd be
like, do some we got them out and write.
There's always gonna be someone new out
there that just surprises you even why
thank you. Got It all figured out. She
hot at least. Oh, she's super high. Uh,
and she has all these other scholars.
Like she has monkeys scores, cat scholars.
Like her whole house has a skulls and
then she has jars. It's so healthy.
And one of the chief had like,
it was like a fresh one.
Like I had some meat on it or something.
It's gross.
A smile paid a dude on
craigslist to pull it.
Did she have two feet on his shoulders?
Fucking pair of pliers.
Fucking periscope chicks are
crazy screaming. You haven't
hooked up with her? No,
no, no. I'm not going to
freak me out. Good for you.
So how about this idea of standards?
Naacp lady from Spokane,
Washington to pretended to be black.
This is not real life. This is like
simulation theory and somebody hacked it.
Just playing a joke on this.
It's a fucking good question. Her parents
out or apparently, did you look at her,
look in her eye when the reporter goes,
you could see where everything just,
yeah, in her eye she realized, oh no,
I've been found there's a,
um,
a picture of a before and
after with her and the,
before it was when she was identifying
as white, she's Trans Racial.
When she was identifying as white,
she had freckles and blonde hair and then
all of a sudden she's got that Orange
Tan
thing going on and like,
like legit,
like black woman permie looking hair.
Like she got her hair permed, sexy.
That waitress at the comedy store. You
look at that, look at her hair. I mean,
wow. That's, and she,
she, you would teach,
she taught at a university
level African studies. Wow.
How does no one know her from her past?
That could be such a parent's coming out
and saying that like this. Apparently,
uh, her parents had adopted a bunch of
brothers and sisters that were black,
I think. Was that what it was? Four
brothers and sisters that were black.
And so somewhere along the
line she appropriated like
that they were her family
and that she's black and she started
calling them one of them. Our son.
A little boy. Oh boy. Definitely hotter
black though. Yeah. That's a new trend.
She looks hot on the right,
but that can't be her for real.
That's Photoshop shit going on. It's
the whole thing is very, very strange.
It's really strange.
But here's what's even stranger
apparently look at hair. Wonderful.
Apparently the tea out
of the founding people,
like if it was 14 founding people of
the NAACP, um, 10 of them were white.
It was a lot of white people
involved in the Naacp and baby,
this is good about what happens here.
I mean,
not that this lady is crazy and
she's pretending to be black,
but maybe it's good that the conversation
gets brought up and people realize
that like racial equality movement.
It doesn't have to be all black
people and wasn't all black people,
so if it was like there was in there
like her race doesn't have anything to do
with how good she is. They're
like, she's really good at her job.
She's like really into black people.
That's what it is. That's what it is.
Nothing wrong with that. Some people
are really into French history.
Some people are, you know what I'm
saying? She's like top wig. Wait,
what's the new word? You can still
say it's still say wigger. Okay.
It hasn't been stolen it from us yet.
They haven't robbed us of wigger.
It's so weird. The whole thing
is wonderful. It's wonderful.
This lady's wonderful,
but meanwhile apparently she was,
she was good at her job and the Naacp,
they were actually saying,
yeah, she went full.
You got cat yard on her head.
She tried to figure it out like a
bunch of different ways of doing it.
That's when she was like,
I'm going to get found if I keep dying
my hair black and putting that fucking
spray tan stuff is going to
call me by my sheets. Orange.
Hold up.
The whole thing is so amazing.
It's amazing. And she browses
on fleek. She sued school.
What?
Naacp imposter sued
school over race claims.
Oh my God. She masqueraded
as a black, as black, uh,
once sued Howard University for denying
her teaching posts and a scholarship
because she was a white woman.
The smoking gun is learned. Whoa.
I'm older than her.
Wow.
She
graduated from the historically black
college with a master's of fine arts
degree. That's so interesting. So in 2002,
she sued the school that is
so interesting. And she was
teaching somewhere else.
Right? Was she teaching there
where she teaches somewhere else,
but she was teaching like
African related courses.
She's just really in the Africa.
Imagine people.
But let's put yourself in her shoes.
I'm not saying the trans ratio is real.
Okay. I'm not saying you should be able
to just identify with a different race,
but if you could, she would be a really
good argument for it. Right. Okay.
She's got black people in her
family that she loves dearly. Right.
She maybe identifies with them.
She went to an all black college.
She was teaching African studies and
she was running the fucking NAACP.
I mean, if anybody can be trans racial,
that lady was kicking ass at it.
Absolutely right.
You got to say,
I'm fucking impressed with what she's
done to her love of African people of
black people has let her do an
amazing job in several areas.
Right. I want to see your
wider Facebook page looks like.
How does a a boyfriend or somebody that
she dated not come out and say something
like, look, this chick is
really, they might not know why.
Really annoying. No, no, no,
but you know what you mean.
Put more makeup on and she just hides
from you and the fucking curtain in her
house is closed. Like drag.
She keeps all the lights off.
She kicks you out at night.
I can't sleep at anybody.
You got to go eat the greatest chick ever.
I don't have to sleep at her.
As soon as you leave, you hear the
compressors have written machine.
She's fucking spraying herself.
The big airbrush can like she's
fucking detailed a Chevelle.
She had to have gotten
spray Tan thousand percent.
There was a spray tan or
somewhere that newer secret,
you know they had to bring it over
for the big umbrella. Yeah. Yeah.
Well this is like, did they, don't they
have a better way of doing that now?
How do they do that? They still make you
stand in and spray to make it realistic.
That's the best way. I mean, you have
the rub on kind of stuff like that,
but you can't usually get it
even enough unless you really,
she just spent all day doing
it. How weird are we? Not We,
because I haven't done it.
I don't think you're doing it.
That people are going and getting fucking
spray Tan. I mean that is so insane.
You're going to end again. Die Sprayed
all over. Your body stinks too,
but just fucking weird. It's just
weird and it wears off in like a day.
You could get two days or whatever it is.
Get the abs sprayed on it though.
You can.
Yeah.
So retarded and people not have time
to lay in the sun anymore. Our Toe.
Maybe you live in Seattle?
Yeah, there's no room.
I just know from girls that you were like,
oh,
I have to have photo shoot tomorrow so I
have to get spray Tan because I tan all
day to day and just, you
know, it's a timing thing.
Yeah, I get it. And it's
also skin cancer thing.
Some chicks don't want to get skin cancer.
You know,
standing out in the sun is
not good for you apparently,
which is fucked because you need
the sun for Vitamin D, Vitamin D,
You need vitamin a.
The fuck.
I don't put sunscreen on. I'm out. I
don't give a shit. You're an animal.
Look at you. You don't give
a fuck. You do it in spurts.
A little little spots. You don't go
out there for eight hours at a time.
I used to landscape when they'll
fucking shirt on. I just did it too.
I can have a tan you a check.
That's what everybody did back then.
Yeah.
Nobody wore sunscreen when we were kids.
We put oil on and we did the opposite.
We got that oil just can't,
especially in like Massachusetts,
you know your summers a week long and
you've got to get it in while you can.
Absolutely. I went up two notches on
a scale of one to 10. If I had a tan,
I went from like a four to a six.
So I had like a three month window where
I was a sex. I had to try to clean up.
When you're young, especially,
you've fucking making moves.
You like to tell you where the chain,
the chain.
What about Cologne?
Probably try it.
That's it.
Your card Anwaar right and pull out the
green Polo had a green polo has got that
shit too. You know what's the
fucking stand by old spice? God Damn.
I still use well it's nice
after old spice was good.
You didn't shower in that time and
just throw it on. Throw those medicine.
Yeah, dad's kit. You bought them.
Did you hear about that fucking
guy that cut some dude's throat?
He was one of those uh,
one of those straight razor or
shaver dudes and a barbershop. Oh No.
He just sliced this dude's
throat and ran away. Yeah,
and they caught him and apparently
had a history of mental illness.
Didn't even know the
guy who's throaty cut.
Just slashed this fucking guy's
throat. Shit. Yeah, the guy lived.
God's going to be okay. It didn't do
a good job of thrash and his throat,
Mr. Big artery, or maybe he was able
to plug it up. Whatever the guy did,
but fucking amen.
That's like the,
the number one thing that
everybody's worried about.
What those fucking straight razors,
you know,
like what would happen if I just randomly
got a nut and this nut decided to cut
my throat. That's why I go
to dollar shave club. Joe,
look at this sentence to Barbara.
Thursday to 10 years in prison for
inexplicably slashing customer's throat
during a haircut and shave
before peddling away on his bike.
You guys,
Navy Petty Officer Timothy Von 33 was
at Vic's barbershop in imperial beach,
just south of San Diego for a haircut.
And October when Barber Daniel,
Roberto Flores calmly slashed
a straight razor across Vons.
Throat twice. Whoa. Mr. Flores.
Waiting until people left the room
to street. Deputy district attorney,
Laura Evans said he insisted on
trimming the victim's beard. He said,
I could cut your throat.
And then he did Jesus Christ.
I want to know what was leading up
to that though. Was the guy being a,
you know the odd,
the petty officer was he just like being
a jerk the whole time looking at me.
He said his,
uh,
his training as a medic kicked in the
guy whose throat got cut and allowed him
to save his own life despite
severe injury and blood loss.
It's been hundreds of
hours of physical therapy,
surgery and psychiatric treatment trying
to recover fucking a man to damn who?
They didn't know each other. There was no
conflict or argument before the attack.
That's so crazy.
That's only 10 years in jail.
What's,
how's that guy got to get fixed?
What are they going to let him out in
five? If it doesn't kill anybody, how,
how's that going to go?
Like anybody who does that,
you need to kill that person.
You don't put them in jail for 10 years.
You out of your mind field and Texas and
let Ted Mnuchin a helicopter and shoot
at them. Pigs take them down to where
Ted news just shooting those pigs.
Shoot him in the knee caps. Just
let the pigs eat them. Fuck you.
I'd rather watch that. Yeah, fuck
you. Fuck you. You can't just do that.
You can't get out of jail in
10 years. That's crazy. 10
years. Not that much time.
10 years ago was 2005 that's not enough
time to go to jail for trying to kill
someone with a straight razor and I'll
probably be out in eight. Fuck that.
That's ridiculous.
Did you watch Jeff Ross's roast of the no,
I did not. I heard it was awesome. I've
seen it. I heard it was great though.
I love the fact that he did it.
I want to talk to him about it cause
he wrote a really good thing for the
Huffington post the other day about
the system. About the penal system.
Not understanding it once you get inside
of it and see how how fucked up in
nightmare I should is the girls were
pretty hot in there. Really? Yeah.
There was a few really hot ones. No
Shit. Yeah, it was kind of weird.
I would imagine there's a lot of crazy
bitches that are hot and fuck up and do
something stupid. One up getting
locked up. That makes sense.
Why would you think that girls in prison
wouldn't be hot? I know because of me.
How many crazy girls do you have?
I dated that we're one step away
from being in jail or oh yeah.
You could have gotten a few
of them arrested if right.
I want to me judging a friend that
just got out after nine months,
like a nine and a half on a scale. I want
to tag how a motherfucker hot though.
Yeah. All of that's all right. Yeah. You,
you get them to the point where
they're ready to kill you. Yeah.
And then somehow or another you
escape with your life sucks.
But if there was a fucking
camera on the wall, oh,
there's drop cams everywhere
nowadays show. Oh,
I got that shit secured. God Damn,
dude, I don't know what you're doing.
Everybody gets mad at you.
I'm not doing enough,
I guess.
Whatever it is.
Yeah.
Do you have, do you, do you usually have
crazy girls in your life, Jim? Oh yeah.
He's a comic. Yeah. Mostly my whole
life. Your whole life pretty much.
Was there one that was most crazy?
Like was there a good story to it?
Milligan of them? I'm trying to think, but
yeah. You always attracted to it. Yeah.
I always wanted the crazy one after the
show. I was dancing on top of the bar.
Whipping her out.
Yeah.
Going to be fun. Yeah. Ooh. But depending
upon how crazy the personality is.
I met a gypsy the other day and I remember
we talked about Gypsy's recently. Uh,
I think we were sitting in this
chair song. Yeah. But she's a gypsy.
She doesn't have a house. A house? No.
Does that mean she just goes from one
millionaire's house to another million?
She's a millionaire. Gypsy girl. Wow.
Just hangs out. She's like, yeah,
just hang out at by pools and stuff.
There are girls that are like that.
There's guys I know guys like that.
He's always like,
he's an older gentleman and he's kind
of quite a bit of money and he's in his
sixties he's never been married and a
hill invite like really hot chicks to stay
at his place and they live
with them all the time.
Like he's always got like some new
nutty 10 let's live in with them.
And I want like, what do you and you
fucking her. I was like, wow, I'm trying.
I'm like Jesus Christ like,
but he would like bring them
in and that was the thing.
He would be like buy them stuff, get
them cars and they could live with them,
you know, and he would
try suit. He was like,
it's really mismatched cause he's not
a good looking fellow. He would also,
he would bring them in and
they would live with them.
And he tried super duper hard to get it.
Sometimes you get it,
but oftentimes it just be a disaster.
They couldn't,
he couldn't get laid and he's paying
for everything and they're living with,
I would do it, I would have a new guy
rule, but I've been in the cars and stuff,
but they can just crash there. No guy
rule. I can't bring guys over. No guys.
Yeah. Sometimes you know it sounds like
a sugar daddy thing. I had just strip,
I used to date, she had a sugar daddy and
she would just buy them all a sh buyer,
all the shit, which is Greg
because I didn't have to buy it.
And then I got the appointment.
I go, you know what?
Maybe he should stuck at me some
shit cause I'm letting her go out.
He's trying to fuck her obviously.
Oh. And I'm like, oh gosh,
do I remember it was a VCR.
I'm like,
well get me a VCR because I don't want
to put up with their shit. Me and,
and then she come on with a VCR. It's
like I need a PCLR. I'm like, beautiful.
I actually went on a date with them in
a limbo and pretend that I was the guy
friend and bad mouth myself for an
hour in front of this guy. You know,
don't have boyfriend of hers. Like
a, yeah, he's a real dick. Oh my God.
And we went to a mall and I picked out
like the like 20 cds he bought me and I
think he bought me like a,
I forget what was like a Walkman at the
time or something like that. I'm like,
yeah, I'll take one. And I'd be like,
sure, you seem like a good dude.
This fucking bad.
My mind and the guy's holding her hand
and the Limo and I'm just sitting there
like the friend am, I don't
give a shit. I'm getting cds.
It's a strong pimp move.
I tried to get a TV but it
he wasn't going forward.
Wow. See a lot of these
guys that rocket like this,
the reason why they have two is
because of prostitution laws.
If prostitution was legal,
there's a lot of these older creep Zoya
dudes that are just out there trying to
make it happen. It just tough action,
you know, unless you're paying for it,
very tough to get someone love
you for who you are. They're like,
if you had these really high
standards and your gross, yeah,
but if you've got a ton of
cash and prostitution's legal,
if they just made
prostitution legal in America,
you'd have exactly the same amount
of hose. Okay. Exactly the same.
Listen to me, they're not going to.
More people are not going to be hoes.
Hoes are hoes are ready.
They're just doing it in weird
ways and maybe it'd be better.
Prostitution was legal.
He found a exactly who the home safer.
Exactly. Tax Pay.
Exactly. Amazon one click.
Right. Nothing wrong with
it. It's just sex. Is it okay
to get, get a massage? Yes.
It's okay to pay someone to
suck your deck. It just is.
Yes, it should be. You know,
and these guys shouldn't have to move
these fucking girls in. Buy Him cars.
It's rude by the guy friends, VCRs, and I
shouldn't have to do it. I felt bastard.
He's, I'm figuring he's trying
to bang my check. Right.
So at least I should get
some gifts out of it. Now,
how did you wind up ending this whole
relationship? You know, it was a stripper,
so it was just, I mean with him, I
get him out of your life.
It seems like you would want some return
for his investments he was doing at
what? He was juggling like three
different ones and he just never,
I think he was fucking wine,
but he wanted to fuck all three and
course and my check had boundaries
while she said it wasn't, no, I wasn't
around. She said she was no way.
I'm not going to sleep with him,
but that he bought her tits to,
she wanted me to buy her tits,
tits and he bought her tits.
Holy Shit. Did you, did you guys go to
dinner with this guy? Yeah, just, yeah,
we went to dinner. Not just at night.
I only met him that one time. Oh, okay.
I'd be at the Bardo cause you know,
shook it down.
He always comes in a strip club and sits
there and all the girls come around.
I was right across the bar just sitting
there just watching this guy. I'm like,
I'm fucking that tonight.
Keep giving her money. Oh,
let's just take a meter to diner.
She's taking me to dinner
later with that money. Okay.
You're the guy when the always people
always talk about like strippers,
crazy boyfriends. That's you. Yeah. Yeah.
It was like the central one and I
was like cutting lawns at the time.
I was making like eight bucks an hour
and this guy's truck and this guy is
probably big at like 300 grand a year, so
that's pimpin. You're tactically pimpin.
Yeah, in a way, you know.
I mean not full on Pimpin,
but that's pretty [inaudible]
respect. I really needed a PCR. Yeah,
I did. I just, I respect that
hustle. I've done the same stuff.
I've added things too when I did it.
Veronica Ricci, I added things to her.
Amazon wishlist,
like Xbox games and stuff.
This is a new world, this world of
Amazon wishlist where girls can say,
I want you to buy me stuff.
Like they have a list.
We go and you can just buy their shit.
Go by him, Shit. And they go, oh my God.
Thank you so much.
Really thank you so much Jim Florentine.
This jacket is amazing. It's
everything I wanted. It's just so nice.
Kim have fans like you.
You're the best fans in the world.
Kim Congdon just got the next box of one.
She's somebody bought her Xbox one.
She has a wishlist comic
with a wishlist wishlist.
I tell everyone I little Esther
has one and he's done one. Uh, not,
I have a desk squad one that had like,
I used to have one,
but the death squad studio
one, which was like, oh,
I need this mic stand and stuff like that.
People would buy it. Yeah. Cool. Wow.
But a little Esther would have one and
I would have access to her wishlist, uh,
when I dated her.
So an add to all these like black dildos
and stuff to it and like fight and she
just, so she would go on the
podcast and she'd be like, guys,
I have an Amazon wishlist.
Please give me something.
And she didn't know I added
all this shit to it. Right.
So she was just getting sent vibrators
and anal beads and she's like,
what's going on? Did she get upset?
Was she happy in the long run?
She used a mom. Sure. Yeah.
Yeah. So cause he'll guy
comics do this too. Damn.
[inaudible] never heard of
a guy called Josh Lewis.
Guys have come guys have wishlists comic.
Yeah,
you can look up anybody
who has a wishlist. Really?
Now it is dude guy comics that
have a wishlist named one.
Wow.
That's what we're talking about.
Does he? I'm sure he does. Does
he? Come on, I'll find one for you.
Didn't find if it's Thomson grow.
I highly doubt it.
I highly doubt Chrysler has one too.
No,
I don't think any of them have a wishlist.
Wishlist where they want you to buy them.
Shit that could see like a
struggling comic that has
got no money. It's like, Hey,
if I can get some whatever, if
I need something, maybe Ben,
the someone that's established,
but there's no reason for that.
I can't even see a struggling
comic doing it. Like what?
What would you want someone to buy
you? Like what? What do you know?
What are you doing tires for your car.
The relationship the girl has. All right,
when she puts up with those Amazon
wishlist things, the relationship is like,
look, this is a box. We can mail me shit.
Like all you have to do is just go
through the electronic things right here.
Press this, click that and I'll get
some shit. Some money we'll be missing.
But you're not going to notice that,
but well,
you are going to notice the fact that
I'm going to go, oh my God. Thank you.
These are exactly the shoes that I
wanted and I was saving up for them so it
meant so much to me.
That's all they need.
I bought her, I bought her shoes. Teen.
I have them on now. Yeah, they
have. They do a lot of that, right.
Tell him skirt has one.
He has a wishlist. Yeah.
Well he's asking people to buy him shit.
Please read the list.
He's got last man standing on DVD.
I'm going to ask him right now.
He's got red state a grass.
Uh,
he's got a bunch of movies mall.
I survivals tail white.
This is what he wants from people.
I think so this might,
I mean it's just as wishlist.
It's not like,
like a lot of people have wishlist but
I don't think they like pimp them out.
Like hey you know, here's my
wishlist. Buy me something.
It's more of like things that they're,
they want to get eventually.
I think you know I'm going to ask him,
do you have an Amazon wishlist?
If so lose my number. Yeah, he
actually, he's has a few of them.
It looks like he has a
few of them. Yeah. Let me,
let me see if Joey Diaz has one so
I bet he does. It's all
shit. His wife wants
that. That is that wishlist thing is
very strange. What's going to be way,
way stranger is that within two or three
decades we're not even going to have to
go to the store to buy shit.
Like everything leave be sent to you
through the internet or it's going to be
three d printed. That's going to
be the vast majority. Fuck yeah.
I mean as long as it makes
sense like size wise,
like you could three d print a table
this big in the in the machines that most
people are going to have in their houses.
But I really believe that there's going
to be a time in our lives where people
are going to be making most of the
stuff that they are going to download
instructions and have a
fucking printer in their house.
It prints it just like
it prints a an image.
They're going to be able to do that with
actual three dimensional things like
with high certainty.
Did you know that uh,
uh,
did you see that new printer
where it's like a liquid based uh,
printer where it doesn't,
it prints different,
it's a different kind of three d
printer technology that they just may,
where it actually comes from the
bottom and they use like an error.
So like it pulls the item out
of all like a liquid bad ass.
Yeah.
There's a few different methods.
They use different ways of
heating the little particles,
those little pellets they use to fill.
It's a bunch of different
methods of doing it,
but apparently they're saying that
like what we're seeing is the infancy.
This is like the model t's of these
fucking things. Just like old printers.
You remember those sprinters
was, it did. It did. It did.
It was super slow and shitty and
it was blocky. Never really looked,
told like you like dark at the
top and the bottom and be light.
They were dog shit. Dot Matrix
Printer. Now you can do,
you can get these fucking printers that
print photographs on photograph quality
paper and it looks like an HD
photo. You're like, Holy Shit,
I'm looking at like a really
nice photograph and you
can print it off of a home
computer printer. It's fucking nuts. Well,
they're going to have
that with this 3d shit.
They're going to have three d objects
and you're going to just need the raw
materials.
You're going to have like
a jug of aluminum and you
know a big fucking thing of
all the different minerals that you're
gonna need to create these things.
And then the computer is going to
figure out where to put everything.
It's going to be nuts. It's going
to be really weird. Real weird.
Now they're going to be
able to do with biology.
That's when Shit's gonna get real weird.
If,
if technology continues where they're,
they can manipulate biology and they're
pretty close to be able to do that.
Now they're doing weird.
Different things are splicing different
genes and shutting off different genes
and punched once.
If they do that and then that becomes so
commonplace that it starts getting its
hand somehow or another
in the public of that.
But public gets a hand on it and the
public community and relate their own DNA.
Like you can have your own build a pet.
Like you have a machine
where you can build a pet,
people are going to make like half
polar bear have fucking Hawk things.
I mean just imagine how fucking bizarre
once people can actually manipulate life
and create like their own versions of
animals and shit, which just to be chaos.
Yeah. You just choose the perfect
puppy. Like, I want to shit too,
but I want to have that black on the
back and white in the front and it just
prints it out and it
comes to life immediately.
And if some asshole uses it wrong cue
mansion if feel like hanging out in your
house and the next door neighbor's
house explodes with baboons.
Baboons are running out of his house,
like just fucking asshole on his printer.
He's making these fucking Babbo.
It's full grown baboons.
He prints them out and they just come
tumbling out of some chamber that he's
gotten his basement.
That's a lot of there.
I mean they're going to be able to do
some weird shit. That thousand years.
Think about a thousand years ago,
the best shit you had was a horse.
That's the best thing. The wagon
behind the horse. I mean that's okay.
If you had some shit you had to
pull around, but the horse was,
the way he got around the idea
that you could fly a plane.
Like if you could go back to the 12
hundreds and tell them about air travel,
how easy it is to get to Paris.
How easy it is.
Like in a day you could be in China,
they'd be like,
what the fuck are you even
talking about, man? But yeah,
you getting a two and it flies to
the, shut the fuck up. Just stop.
That's what it's going to be like
for us thousand years from now.
What they're going to be able
to do with bodies and with,
with electronics and what they're
going to be able to do with technology,
it's going to make,
we're living in the cave era.
We're living in some bizarre like static
world that we can't manipulate and
that's going to seem ridiculous
to people in the future.
Will they be able to cure cancer?
I want Jane Diseases that won't be on it.
So people will live to whatever age.
I can't imagine.
I think there's gonna come a point in
time if you, if you just follow the curve,
right?
Go back from how quickly people died
of illnesses a thousand years ago,
how most illnesses that came along,
they were pretty severe.
They'd have a big impact like you,
you would,
you could easily lose 20% of the
population of your city and some sort of a
plague.
And they had a bunch of those,
the bunch of plagues they had plagues
that wiped out 60 70% of the population
and they have just an insane plagues.
That doesn't really happen anymore. Okay.
So just think about the,
all the different medications
that scientists have come up with,
all the different treatments for diseases
that medical biology is constantly
evolving and getting better at figuring
out a way to detect things early.
And it's safer time to be like a person
who needs medical assistance now than
ever before, ever. In human
history part far, this is not even,
not even a remote comparison.
Right? Well, if that keeps going,
where's it going? It's getting better.
They're getting better at fixing bodies.
They're gonna be better at fixing bodies,
and eventually there's going
to be genetic manipulation.
When those two things combined,
it's like the only thing that's
gonna kill you as trauma.
Only thing that's gonna kill people.
It's like accidents and
things that they can't fix.
That's what's going to kill people and
they're going to get some heart attacks.
They're going to get to a point
where they can fix all that shit.
They're going to be able to reintroduce
different genes into your body,
so there'd be able to introduce different
genes to your heart that make your
heart work different. They have this
fucking shit that they're working on.
That spider silk.
It's,
it's an artificial human skin
that's a hybrid with spider silk.
It's going to be bulletproof. They're
going to have bulletproof human skin.
If this works, Holy Shit. Exactly.
What they're going to be able to do a
thousand years from now is outside of the
realm of anyone's imagination. The,
the history that we studied today,
when you study Alexander the Great,
when you studied Gingiss con,
if you had to go back in time that far,
the way they lived,
you would still kind of understand
it. You know, you'd still,
we understand the way they
live. We understand that.
They wrote her on horseback.
They got their water from the river.
They had a hunt for their food.
They had no refrigeration.
There's constant war and struggle.
We understand that it's,
they still seem like people,
but what they're going to be a thousand
years from now is going to be nuts.
It's going to be fucking bananas.
Everyone's going to be 20 years old.
There's going to be no disease
and we're going to be freaks.
They're going to be able to
manipulate your genes. You,
you could be like a half eagle person.
He could run around with
feathers grown off your deck.
That's not outside the realm of
possibility. Things are going to get real.
If you have today like people you're
allowed to go, I mean, and you should be,
you're allowed to go to any one of those
body modification places and they put
fucking plates and your
forehead and stretch your
ears out and cut your lips off
or whatever nutty shit you want to
do. Why not let them do it? Who Cares?
But if you want to be like a
half ego person, Ooh, what?
You're going to grow talons.
You're going to be happy.
Go person like we didn't even know you
should you be able to live in a city now
that's going to happen. Half Eagle
people are going to be a reality
analogy,
so what happens?
All the pharmaceutical companies would
all are with no more sickness and all
that other stuff. It's 20%
of our oh cheese. Oh my God,
that lip window. Whoa,
that's, that's rough yet.
Oh my God. Is that real? Yeah. Oh my God.
That guy's out a hole in the side of his
face like a second mouth and he sticks
his tongue through it. Oh
my God. That's crazy. Yeah.
Oh Geez. How did they drink koolaid?
It just comes out their mouth.
I guess they have to use a straw.
Everything there must have to
drink everything with his draw.
Imagine watching that dummy eat.
Blowjobs squirts right back at you.
What is that one of the, in the group
down there with the Tattoo. That guy.
What is going on with him?
Oh my Jesus Christ.
Holy Shit. Fuck. What is he doing?
Look at this nose as these giant holes.
His nostrils.
He's had holes not in the bottom where
the nostril hole is, but on the sides,
holes created and then stretched way
out the size of a quarter so you can see
right into his nasal cavity.
And then he's got those enormous ears,
stretchy things,
which I've gotten pretty used to.
They're so normal now and he's got tattoos
all over his face and his side of his
head and his eyebrows and Jesus. Fuck
Dude. What happened and how well,
who did you wrong son
number.
Simpler Times where he just had it
on the left side. You weren't gay,
the right side. You were
gay. Now that's all it was.
Did anyone that you knew when you were
growing up have a facial piercing? Never.
No. No. Right? I can't think of anybody.
You know we had hoops or not hoops,
but I mean, did you meet anyone
that even at a nose ring,
when did you meet someone with a nose
ring? Nose Ring was college about 93 yeah,
that's what I saw. Chick
started went and guys toe. Yeah.
I'm trying to figure it out. When
I saw my first nose ring. Joe,
didn't you have your belly button
pierced? No, it was my deck.
I was going to have it connected to
my belly button with like a chain,
like a wallet chain. Did you have,
did you have any hearing? I had to,
I had to it in the last year. You couldn't
put it in a ride. I had a fake diamond,
but it would wear a gold hoop.
Gold. Who? It's his picture.
Joe.
I saw you on Ariadne's uh,
Instagram wearing the extensions
that will put some of my hair on.
That was funny as fuck. I think I was
actually Megan's Megan old Levy. The,
I'm a broadcaster interviewer.
Yeah, I think it was her hair.
I don't know whose hair it was one of
those chicks I still funny to see or any
style. It helped with getting the
checks. So it was always covered.
My Dad didn't like it so I,
I take them out when I wasn't around,
but he couldn't see it anyway
because my hair was really long.
But he need some peacock feathers,
man.
But Bond Scott from ACDC had an earring
and each year I said, and you're like,
wait a minute, you too. So some guys would
go with both like, Hey, I'm not, you know,
cause if it was in the right ear,
that meant you were gay.
But if you had them both, he's like, well,
Bon Scott had my bald so I can have
in both. I never went bold move.
I know it was the both Eddie Bravo
used to do it. I do both. Awesome.
I could still do it in both there.
They're both still.
They haven't grown together
yet. How dare you? So weird.
Yeah, it's a, we are
saying what you're allowed,
but it's weird what you're allowed to
and not allowed to. I'm not allowed.
Me Personally,
I'm not allowed to hang out with
anybody that his eyebrow piercings.
If you're a dude and you know, vibe Raul
piercings. I looked in my rules and I go,
oh look,
I'm so sorry I have rules.
I don't hang out with any dudes
of eyebrow piercing. I gotta go.
I liked that role. That's fair
enough. But it's, it's different.
Like Cara Santa Maria was
our friend is awesome.
She's got a lip ring and normally I
look at people with lip rings. I'm like,
what is that dumb shit about?
Well I got metal coming out of your face,
but she could pull it off.
Like it just depends on the individual.
It doesn't even, I don't even
notice it. She has a lip ring.
It just seems like a part of her.
She's so smart and interesting.
Talk to doesn't really kind of
affect how you think of her,
but a lot of people like you meet a
girl with a lip ring like listen crazy.
What's going on with your
face? Huh? I ain't got there.
Three ring binder come down here.
Fucking lip.
I don't like the pussy periods because
I feel I'm going to tear it or rip it or
something and then it just, I don't like
it. That's a strong statement to grow.
It gets her pussy pad. I've had a couple
of, it doesn't really do anything.
I know down. Woo, what are you doing
down there? Why am I adding hardware?
One this one check at a little bar bell.
She was you lifting weights was a pussy.
Well, some girls will
do key goals, you know?
I mean that's essentially like doing
some Bruce Lee dynamic tension exercises
for your pussy. She could masturbate
by just tying a kite to it.
You know Bruce Lee used to do that.
Bruce least fucking,
he's to do these exercise
where you're just tensed up.
Girls do that with their
poster that it works too. Well,
there's a woman in Russia,
they can carry weight.
She has the world record for the amount
of weight that she can carry with her
pussy. Like she shove something up or
post it clamps down on it and she can lift
weights. Like I'm talking like fucking
heavyweight, like 50 60 pounds. Pussy.
Yeah. It's like a vice grip in
there. This is a Russian woman.
I wouldn't want my cock in there. Yes,
you probably wouldn't. First of all,
you wouldn't because you wouldn't want
to put your cock in the pussy of a woman
who's been practicing something like that.
Like what is wrong with her that what
she's, she's not just practicing it.
She's entering contests.
It's not like she's at home in the
privacy of her own home. I'll get,
she's got some stuff stuck in
their pussy and she's dangling
like a noodle or something. She's so
she's got it in between her legs. Okay.
But um, so she holds a world record for
the amount of weight that she can carry.
I don't know if it's hers. It's
her. It's all in Russia. Oh.
So now she's got an actual physical
weight that she's hanging from her pussy.
This is insane. Look at
this. She's picking up this
heavyweight with her. Was He?
Oh my God.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
She's just letting you know that
she will fuck the life out of you.
That don't come near me.
She's just letting you know.
If she gets a hold of you,
that Super Pussy,
she's going to lock on to you and you're
going to have to use 50 60 pounds of
force just to get away from her.
That's a fucking statement.
That's why you just try for anal
first. Go right to the ass. Yeah.
Just go right to the assets are not like,
you know,
I like this better and then we'll,
we'll get to the pussy.
Could you imagine what kind of ask power
she has and everyone has asked me or
right. People used to clenching and
shits holding in farts. You know,
that's a common thing,
but to, I don't know.
How common is it for girls to actually
work on tightening their pussy?
Have you had a girl ever squeezer asshole
muscle while you're in her asshole
before? No. It's cool. No, I never
did either. They were just mad.
I was in there. There were
clenching their fists. It's weird.
I'm sure she's trying to shut you
out. Sorry. That's just trying to cut.
It's an analogy for your whole life.
I went through this part
where this girl was dry.
I dated for a long period of time.
It's mad at me for it.
So for a month she wouldn't let me have
vagina sex that could only have butts
sex and you think that sounds awesome.
But after like the third day,
it's just awful.
But that was one thing that she
would do all the time just to do.
That was her punishment. Yeah.
It was a horrible punish.
You think that's a great punishment?
That's a horrible punish.
Why was it horrible? Because you don't
want to miss x more than three times.
You know? You're like, all right, I'm
done. I don't want this anymore. You know?
So she was like trying to play like
some sort of psychological game.
Just give you the ass and then you
will never ask they ass again. Right?
Hmm. That's the kind of
girls that Dave, Brian,
that's how they think that or
why I don't like it anymore, man.
And that you do that squeezy thing.
She'll do that squeezy thing and it just
feels like there's like something else
in there. It's just too tight. Just too
sharp corners. It's like the Samsung Edge.
How many girls do you think actually
like work on that? Do those key goals?
Is that a common thing? Yeah. Especially
yoga girls. Definitely yoga girls. Yeah.
Cause they're just tightening
their pussy all the time and yoga.
And there's like exercises you
could do when you're just sitting.
You could also use those balls and
stuff. Like dudes can do that too. Right?
That's those. Um, for uh, uh,
Kama Sutra, you know, the, the,
the different strategies of,
uh, what's that type of, uh,
what does that type of,
um, tantric, thank you.
What are you supposed to hold in your
calm and not supposed to have orgasm on
edge all the time? Joe, you ever edge
is supposed to like just hold, hold, oh,
well supposed to keep it inside of you
and if you can hold it tight enough,
apparently you internally orgasm
internally. I don't know what that means.
I guess you have the same feeling, but
it's more intense, but you don't come.
So you're probably also an idiot by the
time of the third week rolls around.
All you're thinking about is how fucking
horny you are everywhere you got like
Jesus Christ because you haven't
common three, four weeks.
It's terrible idea. That's what people
used to do when they didn't have cable.
You know, they'd practice different
ways to hold them there. Calm.
Just to make life more interesting.
Just just hurry up and come and watch
game of Thrones. Just get in there.
I'd rather a lot of just slide out for
a second. I, oh, sorry. I, you know,
give me a second. I think I heard
someone's at the door to suck a regroup.
I'm not going to hold it in.
Clench down that muscle.
So weak. Even if you lift weights like
you, you could have like the best grip.
Give a guy a fucking manly hand shake.
How all your bud. Nice to meet Ya.
You'd be a stud,
but that muscle that controls your Dick.
Every guy's got this
week just fucking lazy.
It gets tired and fatigued.
Easy.
Like you could clamp your jaw shut
for a fucking hour. You get to fuck up
you, you clamp your Dick tried to
squeeze down your Dick for 20 seconds,
you're ready to blackout. It's just
such a weak muscle like right now,
try squeeze your Dick Hall.
Also.
I have no endurance on
my dick squeeze muscle.
I wonder if you practice it,
would it really get to a point where
you could be like the male equivalent to
that lady that carries bricks in
her pussy? What is this? How men,
how can men do Kegel exercises?
Why would they do that?
Halfway through urination? Try to
stop or slow the flow of urine. Yeah,
that's possible. It's not fun. Don't
tense the muscles in your buttocks,
leg or abdomen,
and don't hold your breath when you
can slow or stop the flow of urine.
You've successfully located these muscles.
Okay?
So don't tense the muscles
in your buttocks, legs
or abdomen, and don't hold
your breath. Okay, so you're,
you have to figure out how to
stop the p from the middle,
like some instead of
like squeezing your butt.
Like if you had to stop peeing in the
middle of PN who'd clamp your butt shot,
you would squeeze down your Dick and
you would try to stop the stream.
What they're saying is don't
tense the muscles in your butt,
your legs or your abdomen,
and don't hold your breath that you could
actually just develop a squeeze that
could stop pee from coming out without,
without moving anything else,
but your deck muscles can't believe
I'm talking about can you flip your
pick up and hit your belly like,
like we were in. It's hard.
Can you like flick? It was
really ridiculous. Questions are
stupid as fuck. Now. Can you do that?
Can you move your Dick?
Who knows Brian?
No one's sitting around moving their
deck. What? The hotties out your hands?
Yeah, just flick it up.
What? You can't do it? Yeah,
you got my balls way mind down so
it's not going to go off. Yeah,
I could flick it. I can just
like sit there and just be like,
if it's hard I could just go like flick
night and flip my stomach. That stuff.
They can do that dude.
He's just said he can't.
I know you're talking about, no, you're
talking about and it's so worth it to us.
He's like,
I can muscle like remember when you're
five and your friend nipple first learned
how to whistle. I can whistle. Can you
whistle? Everybody can fucking whistle.
All right dude. Yeah,
get smacked my belly.
Every guy who has a hard on can do that.
If your dick gets hard, you tense it up.
It hits your stomach.
That's how it's designed.
My molds shots when I want to pull it
cools. My mom plays to like close it,
but she didn't even know how to do that.
Can you flip back or a pen in your mouth?
What
you like flip it.
You put a grape on the head of your
deck and it flip it up. Do you do that?
I can do that. You've never done
that? I've done that. Definitely done.
I've done that. You put a grape on
your deck and flipped it in your mouth?
I don't believe in them.
No, I didn't get my mouth.
I said try to flip it in your
mind. How far does it go up? Uh,
first of all,
I don't believe that at all because I
believed that if you did start it and you
got close to your mouth,
you would keep flipping into your face
until you caught it around with me.
No, Joe, I can do it. Why should you
put it on your helmet? Flip it up. Yeah.
Did you get brain damage this
weekend or something to haul it away?
It's not smoking real.
So something wrong with you.
You seem like there's really
something wrong with you today.
Your sentences are so ridiculous.
Very not smoking cigarettes and I have it.
I slept with a patch on,
I forgot to take off.
Yeah, you cannot leave those on the kill.
You at least give you a heart attack.
So throw that out though. Don't leave that
on my table. You creep. It's that real.
Why that you can't sleep
with it cause I've, yeah,
you're not supposed to sleep
with them. It's intense.
That's true. I'm pretty sure.
Pretty sure it's supposed
to take those off.
There's like a bunch of different rules
to those things and you can't have too
many of them. Like people have like
four or five of them on and died.
You gotta be fucking careful.
You get at those patches like
especially the variant strength,
you know you're supposed to wean yourself
off to a lighter and lighter patches.
The lightest one.
It's just seems fucked up to me.
The nicorette gum makes the most sense.
It's the grossest you'd taste
nicotine and you want it. It
makes me puke.
Like I will literally Puke if I,
if I hadn't the nicorette
nicotine gum or the mints.
It has like this weird nicotine tastes,
that
soluble Mark Marin's strategy.
He just keeps chewing the nicotine gum.
He's been on the nicotine gum for like
10 years bosses the same way. Guys.
Been Nicorette gum for a year. I think
Marin's actually done with the gum now.
I think it's completely free of the good
for him. That's a hard fucking monkey.
Just the kick that's cigarette
monkey seems like to me.
Out of all the things that I've seen,
people kicked cigarettes seems to be
the toughest. Does not the toughest,
the consequences of going back
on it because if you see guy,
he's got a heroin problem, then he's, he
kicks it and then he goes back on heroin.
He's all fucked up.
His life's a mess.
But if you see God kicked
cigarettes and comes back,
it's just smoking a cigarette,
you know? It was like, ah,
I quit for a little law I couldn't play.
But he's still right there talking to you.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not like someone to quit something
like math or something fucking crazy.
That ruins your life really quick.
Cigarettes is a nice slow burn.
But if you can take that out of it and
you look at it objectively like how many
people do you know that were former
drug addicts? Oh, I know all lot.
A lot of dudes who had
problems with drugs.
How many dudes do I know
that had a problem with
cigarettes and did successfully
kick it? Not that many. Only a few.
I know a lot of people that struggle
with that shit hardcore you,
you struggled with it hardcore are,
he still says he gets cravings for it
and he kicked it a long fucking time ago.
Um, Dunkin's still gets
cravings, you know,
he'll still have a cigarette
every now and again.
Joey will have allow himself a
cigarette every now and again,
which I think is like
super fucking dangerous.
Joey. Joey actually always
doesn't, he always smoked.
There's like e-cigarette
things all the time.
Sometimes he does,
but you remember back in the day he
would allow himself a cigarette every now
and then. Fuck it. Whatever.
I'm not a cigarette.
He's just sitting there
smoking a cigarette.
But he had enough willpower to not
go buy a pack and not keep going.
But um,
that seems to be like as hard a kick
as anything because it seems to me like
when people are like the,
the heroin thing and like people
have like severe pill problems.
Like they look at those
pill problems like, fuck,
I hope those things don't get me again.
You know, if they get off of them,
they look at him like fuck like
that's his fucking pills man.
People don't look at cigarettes
that way they look at it. It's,
it's a much more casual thing
cause it kills you so slowly.
Cigarettes though is have
his has killed coffee for me.
Like right now this coffee is horrible
and I used to love coffee and I can't it,
I don't even want to drink this coffee
now. What are you talking about?
Just because the,
the whole cigarette and
coffee thing together is kind
of made what coffee was in
my head.
So now just this by itself,
it's off white plus your taste
buds are probably coming back now.
What other smoke?
That's a big part of it, dude. You're
do your taste buds get really fucked up.
But cigarettes apparently.
Yeah. I haven't noticed that.
I've just noticed zero energy.
Like I can't stop sleep.
So weird to me that like
chefs would smoke cigarettes.
Like I don't understand that.
Like Anthony Bordain used a small key
quit is the cigarette break. Yeah.
But it's still like if
you're smoking cigarettes,
how do you know exactly what things
taste like of it numbs your taste buds?
I don't know how accurate that really
is because I've quit before for like a
year and I've never noticed
anything with the d.
The taste or the smell is as at
least that drastic of something.
Hmm. I think that's a
pretty commonly known thing.
Like that taste buds come back all of a
sudden full light you don't like anymore.
Yeah, I don't think, I
mean it probably varies.
I mean maybe it doesn't affect you the
way it affects other people like you.
You think you have a pretty good sense
of taste while you're smoking cigars.
I used to, I, I've noticed
that my tastes like,
I don't really taste things as much
anymore, but I think that's just,
cause I'm old.
That doesn't even make sense. Dying
don't they? When? When you get older.
So we're self diagnosing again.
We did this the other day.
I think that when you're
smoking cigarettes,
I think it's killing all
sorts of shit in your throat.
And the fact that it fucks with your
taste buds. It's not surprising.
You're smoking your taste buds.
The taste buds are in your mouth.
You're flooding your mouth
with poisonous fucking smoke.
Do you still smoke? No, I, I
stopped like 25 [inaudible] seven
years.
It's a hard one to quit.
One of the hardest ones to
quit and way more common.
Also fulfils other ones when
like heroin or math or it's,
it's way more common that people
smoke cigarettes than do meth.
And I smoked for 25 years. Yeah.
And you said you were up to,
I only smoke like eight cigarettes a day.
I wasn't a big smoker where you said two
packs. Two packs of the last six months.
Yeah. Were, yeah, that's why I quit
cause I was like this is ridiculous.
I'm smoking two packs a day now and I
would be like, why am I smoking so much?
And it was,
why were you smoking so much?
I think all the crap that's
happened like the last six months.
So that's a lot of
cigarettes, dude. I stress.
So you stopped and now nothing.
Right,
except this patch but no cigarettes
at all for how long? Seven days.
Whoa. And will they say you have
to get over, what's the hump?
They have like a list that's on the
Internet that shows you like you know from
like day two and three of quitting. This
happens and then a week and it, it, it,
I think it's maybe three months
at that list goes to like,
and after the third month you'll
have 98% less of a heart attack.
Chance and really, and you're
going to grow better fingernails.
I forget what the list said,
but it was involving taste and smells.
Are you really going to stick with
it this time? I don't know. Wow.
That's not as strong fucking night owl.
That's not the one who stayed one thing
being at the comedy store has been
really rough because that place for some
reason you can still smoke on the patio
and everywhere. Almost outside. Yes.
Well all the other bars,
you can't even smoke on patios anymore.
But I think cause it's a,
and maybe you should shut the fuck up
so they don't get rated. Know they know,
but, but uh, but, but it's so,
so much smoke. Everyone smokes.
It's, it's like you get
secondhand smoke. Well,
I just can't stop thinking
about it. So when you go
there, now, what do you do? Uh,
I just, I'm just dead inside. I
don't know. Oh, here's the thing.
Yeah. Isn't that crazy? After 20 minutes,
your blood pressure drops to normal.
Pulse rate drops to normal temperature
in hands and feet increase in normal
eight hours. Carbon monoxide levels
in blood drops and normal. Wow.
It takes eight hours. 48 hours.
Nerve endings start regrowing like,
and it's just like a smell and taste
is enhanced just 48 hours outside of
cigarettes. See, there
you go. Just six days.
Doctors were saying cigarettes are good.
Take him smoke.
I'm doing commercials for them.
I think it was earlier than the sixties,
but maybe 50 shots, right. Was, um,
in that j Edgar Hoover movie and
the j Edgar Hoover movie. Uh,
what's his name? Uh, what
the fuck's his name? Vena.
Leonardo Dicaprio is j Edgar Hoover and
his mother is talking to him about the
doctor prescribing cigarettes for
him, like to match them up. Hey look,
doctors five I'd have to one commercials.
Yeah,
I see you see the ads
cigarettes a good for yet small.
Come look at that five years. Stroke
risk reduced to that of a nonsmoker.
Fights graders though. Still
though. That's great. A
risk of cancer of the mouth.
Throat, esophagus is half that of a
smoker in five years. Just five years.
That's great. In 10 years,
precancerous cells are replaced.
Lung cancer death rate is about half
the rate of a smoker in 10 years.
Life expectancy comparable to a nonsmoker.
If you quit for 10 years,
that's beautiful.
Smoker or a nonsmoker that works at a
paint factory more way more fucked or
black mold in your house.
People that work in like fucking plants
and factories like especially back
before they knew what kills you
and what didn't kill you like yeah.
A lot of people got a fucking
real bad deal like that.
They found out about
that as best as cause.
A bunch of dudes got cancer from as
best as you know, from working on it.
They used to have that as best as that.
Remember that shit they used to a
installation for all the old houses. Yeah.
Houses are filled with cancer.
My body used to work on these old
buildings and the New York in the 80s,
just just like a construction guy,
whatever.
He needs a new lung that was on a lung
transplant list from all that shit.
Just don't put shit in the garbage and
destroying all ripping off walls and
stuff like that. Well, you know,
Donna summer died from lung cancer,
I'm pretty sure, and she died because
she lived near where the towers fell.
A lot of people that live where the towers
fell, including a lot of the firemen,
a lot of the, like a lot of the,
uh, the people that rescued people,
EMT officers, all the, all the
people that worked in that area.
There's a lot of people who got sick
and Donna summer apparently lived,
she had an apartment that was pretty
close to that area and just the shit that
was in the air. I mean you could only
imagine a giant fucking building.
That's what it was. It a hundred stories
or something like that collapses.
Another one collapses right next to it.
All the fucking Dustin Shit
that my building that's
built in the early seventies
so they,
I'm sure to use this past us and,
but then of course I was
at EPA or something came in
and they have to like the
third day said he air quality's fine,
it's harmless tooth and everybody just
worked there and just hung out and they
charity work and should always down there
doing some helping move boxes and shit
like that. Cause they're all
right. I guess it'd be arrows.
Okay.
All those first two drivers,
all the people like the EMT people and
the fire people and a lot of those guys
get sick.
A lot of cops got sick.
A lot of people that live there that
try to come back early, they got sick.
It just only makes sense.
I mean you,
you're not going to have spring fresh
air went to enormous buildings fall.
So that just got declassified the other
day. Did you going to? If there's any new,
some of it,
but there's still a lot missing.
The nine 11 reports. Yeah.
What do you think happened?
I think exactly what they tell
us exactly what they tell us.
Pretty much two dudes in box
cutters took over an airplane,
flew into the twin towers. What do
you think happened? Pretty close.
I think most likely. Almost
exactly like their talent. US,
except for,
well,
I think they capitalized on an event and
I think that's why it looks like they
set it up.
I think that's why one of the reasons
why people have so much of a vested
interest in like trying to prove some
sort of conspiracy with the government and
nine 11 it's cause there's so much
profit that was made off those wars,
especially the warder Iraq.
That's the forget about like what
happened at nine 11 and who caused that.
But it's the reaction to not 11
that's the craziest thing ever.
The craziest thing is how we just
decided to go to war with Iraq, you know,
country that had nothing to do with it.
And then how Burton's getting
these billion dollar contracts,
they're blowing shit up left and
right and like that's, that's,
that had nothing to do
at nine 11 like theirs.
That's like someone in
like Marina del Rey,
you know, picking a fight with
you. So you knew Canada or, yeah,
it's really that fucked up.
It doesn't make any sense at all.
They're totally different countries.
Totally unrelated and that's the most
fucked up thing about it is what they
definitely did.
Like the idea that it was planned,
that it was like they flew through
that that's like so complicated.
Like I don't know if they really
are even capable of doing that.
I don't know if there's a group in the
highest levels of government that's
capable of hiring so many
people to keep their mouth shut.
So many people to engineer this thing
where you got to fly planes and the
building's going to,
are there people with box cutters?
Are there Saudi guys that are
on those planes? Are they,
are they a fucking Hologram?
How you cover all that?
How do you cover the news story?
How do you make sure that
nobody keeps her mouth shut?
no bad motherfucker on the
plane doesn't Chuck Norris,
these fucking terrorist dudes in
the head and take over the plane.
How do you stop all that from happening?
Because it seems to me that like
it would be a lot of fucking,
people would have to be involved
and one person's going to talk.
Absolutely. One's going to fucking talk.
Wired that building for explosives.
Nobody saw him coming in.
There's no video of anybody in
at two o'clock in the morning.
What about the janitor that mops up
didn't see some guys cause they say,
you know they had, the way it came
down, it had to be explosives inside.
Yeah. The the one that's
crazy. Tower seven.
That's the crazy one because that was
the one that wasn't hit by a plane. Yeah,
but what,
what freaks me out is not that,
that they had to have explosives to
des to detonate a building and make it
collapse like that.
That doesn't,
I don't buy that because I don't think
we've ever seen a fucking building that
big collapse. Like how do you know
once it starts going like first of all,
what about the possibility that they
used shitty engineering and terrible
fucking concrete and the unions were
involved and they fucking half assed that
giant building and it fell
apart when a plane hit it.
That seems like the more likely
scenario put that tower seven,
which just goes like this [inaudible]
that's the one that's the most crazy cause
it looks like an implosion but
apparently it was on fire and apparently,
you know the, the entire building
had like some sort of, uh,
underneath the basement they had
some sort of a diesel generator.
So they had these giant drums of
diesel and it all caught on fire.
So it was a raging inferno inside the
building and some people think that
compromise the steel and
made it collapse like that.
But it looks like a fucking
controlled demolition.
That's the one that really looks like
it. Yeah. Twin Towers look like the,
the top fell off and the whole
thing just exploded from the weight.
And when you see all those buildings
that are shooting out that they say is
reminiscent of explosions.
Yes.
But you know that the top of the building
is coming down and crushing all those
floors. Right? That's how the thing is
getting crushed. Right. What is that?
That's pressure. I would happen to me or
pressure windows explode. That's that.
Everyone knows that.
So if you slow something down and you're
showing these windows exploding because
the top is collapsing in the building and
you're saying that's evidence of bombs.
No, it's not. No, it's not.
It's evidence of explosions that are
happening because of compression.
There's a lot of things
going on in that building.
That building is fucking collapsing.
It's fucking billions of pounds of
metal and concrete and it's all falling
apart.
Like you looking at these little slow
motion things and saying that's definitely
bombs. It's not definitely
bumps. It could be bombs,
not definitely bombs though.
It's more likely that that
fucking buildings falling apart.
Supposedly when they built it,
they had it where I was going to come
straight down if there was ever out of a
hurricane or something like that earlier.
Yeah,
that's what I remember reading a
seen a documentary on the trip.
The trade centers getting
built in case dead,
didn't want to just fall over and
wipe out six streets. That is smart.
If you said a belt, it like that
in case something does come Kinda,
you know like yeah, big hurricane or an
earthquake came, it would just wipe out,
you know, a bunch of blocks
and they built it like that.
That would fall straight down like that.
I don't know how they did it,
but I mean that's, that's what
they said in a document. The Guy,
the guys who documentary.
Because could you imagine if that plane
slamming into the building caused that
designed to kick into effect and
that's why I collapsed either way,
man.
That's the only time in our lives and
in the history of the continental United
States. It's been attacked. You know,
that's one of the most fucked up things
about us in comparison to the rest of
the world. Everybody's been
attacked a fucking million. I mean,
just look at all the shit that's
happened in Mexico just in Mexico.
Just fucking Cortez coming over here and
kill him like a fucking million people.
All the crazy as techs that
were killing me. I mean,
there's a lot of attacks and invasions
and shit happened just in Mexico.
Germany's been fucking attacked.
Russia has been attacked.
Everybody's been attacked. England's
been hit with bombs from the Nazis.
Everybody got attacked.
Their spots and France are so fucked up
to this day that you can't go in him for
like a hundred thousand years.
They have like a red zone when they have
this fenced up zone and France real all
from the munitions,
all from unexploded munitions and
the toxins just from World War II.
Dude, it's nuts. Pull, pull up
that article too because it just,
it was a recent article, photos of
Francis Red Zone. It was amazing.
I sent it to Dan Carlin,
who is this guy who has his podcast
called hardcore history and he's got this
insane series on world war one and
how fucked up world war one was.
And this is a part of that,
like this,
this all these munitions and
all those bomb shit. If it's a,
it's an area the size of Paris and you
can't even go near it. Wow. You find it?
Check this shit out.
It's fucking nuts, man.
This is all from the war and
it's, well, this is like, there's,
there's really good pictures of the
actual place. What's that? Yeah. Right.
It looks like a Zombie movie. Yeah.
Yeah. He can't go anywhere near it.
There's like a fence and then inside
that fence it's fucking no man's land.
You just can't get in there.
They bombed that place literally to hell.
And they had all these, and
look at that, look at all,
this is all the shit they're
finding their, they have these, uh,
animals that live there. And they did
tests on the animals, like the wild hogs.
And they,
they were filled with toxins.
All these horrible fucking
chemicals from these explosives,
explosives and what did explode,
what leaked into the soil and they used
gas and I mean this is a nutty fucking
time. Look it fucking bombs.
They foul just laying in a field.
That was when war was war man.
This Dan Carlin thing,
if you don't know anything
about World War One,
I didn't know shit about world war one.
This this Dan Carlin piece
that he's got right now.
It's amazing if you've never listened to
hardcore history is the best podcast on
on history. Yeah, it's amazing.
And he's got this incredible piece
on a World War One. That's that.
He just finished,
I think the last episode he just released.
What a fucking nutty time dude.
That was just a hundred years ago.
These people were fighting in trenches
and shooting at each other from over the
hills.
What's really crazy is they,
these people in World
War one in particular,
they were still wearing like the brightly
colored that people were in the 18
hundreds because they were in like
their grandfathers fucking battle ladder
battle outfits. They had outfits
that were essentially like targets,
like white gloves and white hats and they
didn't have any helmets and they were
walking it all walk,
just walk,
just walk in and fucking shooting people
and then people would shoot back and
they dig a hole and cry and scream.
And that's how they did war.
Fucking nuts, man down. And if it
wasn't for them, we wouldn't be here.
Salou God blessed those fine warriors.
Accomplice
fucked right. God blessed the
troops cut. Y'All fucked does that,
that that just a hundred years ago it was
how they did war. This, this piece is a,
the hardcore history thing.
He talks about the Germans inventing
these new guns that were so powerful.
They used to have to plug up their ears,
they'd plug up their nose,
they would back up 300 yards and when
the thing went off you still had to have
your mouth open or it'll
blow out your eardrums.
So they're packing their packing their
nose, they're packing their ears,
they're plugging up everything.
And you still have to have your mouth
open when it goes off 300 yards away from
you.
Cause the reverberation,
the sound is so powerful that it
literally will blow your eardrums open.
And so they were shooting these fucking
Volkswagen bus size bullets at a,
the people on the other side of forget
who they were shooting them amount.
I forget which country it was they first
used it on but it would just obliterate
with one bullet it would
obliterate like 70 people.
One bullet would just take out 70 people
and they were like, what the fuck?
Before then it was like bullets
[inaudible] at a time share hall,
you should have me,
I should have you Viva La France and you
can fucking went out there and then the
Germans took shit to the next level.
They had this huge gun that they used
to have like tanks would pull it and it
was enormous.
You're talking about this huge cannon of
a weapon and then they had figured out
the distance,
like they had to figure it out,
but like they would launch one bullet,
figure out where you were and they
would lower the gun. A little launch.
A second bullet is nothing you could do,
couldn't get away.
It's things shooting you from miles away.
Were you watching that Dallas
footage the other night? The uh,
what do you mean a gunman?
No, I heard briefly
about it. What happened?
Some guy went nutty and shot at the cops.
Yeah, he got a armored car. Our
van off of uh, looks like Ebay,
somebody found the other
day, the auction listing. Uh,
and it was just completely armored
and he was just shooting and stuff.
But one crazy thing is if you,
Jamie, if you look at my Twitter,
I posted this video of a,
of a guy named Scoota
underscored juice man.
And he was filming on the street
when this was happening. The Guy,
I'm the armored car was just shooting
at cops hitting cop cars and stuff like
that. And he had planted all these
pipe bombs throughout the city.
It was like grand theft auto is nuts,
but this guy was shooting like filming
it and a bullet you could hear wizard
right by his head
is so intense.
Oh my God.
Fuck that. So do you remember that
North Hollywood shootout? Yeah. Yeah.
I was here for that.
Yeah,
we were on the set of news radio
and we all huddled up in the,
in the break room and watching on
television. We were like, what the fuck?
Watching these two dudes with full
armor on and machine guns and shit just
fucking gun down cops.
Did you remember that?
That wasn't the scene that they'd kind
of recreated from the movie heat. Yeah.
Yeah. That was the inspiration of it.
Holy Shit. Yeah. That really happened.
It was called the north Hollywood shootout
to just maniacs to crazy dudes all
fucked up on drugs out of their
mind and just arm to the Dick.
Just their trunk was stuff and cops
had like regular service revolvers and
you're like, what am I going to do with
a fucking nine millimeter against these?
I mean, what's going on here? And some
were just so under gunned. So, um,
I think they changed out
shitload of laws after that too.
About like how much machine
guns you could have right now.
What happens when he starts stockpile
and that kind of ammo and bulletproof
vests and shit. He said I was pretty
much kind of the scene from that movie.
He thinks that was the inspiration for it.
Is this a the new one?
Oh, this is north Hollywood.
Yeah. Okay. So these dudes,
they have full on bulletproof vests,
the whole deal.
They like wearing military
garb and then they,
they have the trunk open and
inside the car it's all guns.
It's all guns and bullets.
And this dude is like,
he's all armored essentially.
And so he's shooting at these cops and
you know the cops are fucked there.
They're hiding, they're
waiting for backup. But it was,
it was really scary because
these guys are kind of idiots.
And it makes you think like if someone
who really knew what the fuck they were
doing, like some real tactical guys
like seals or something like that,
or they went nutty and decided to do this,
you wouldn't need a large group
in order to shut entire city down.
My friend Justin talks about this
all the time cause he knows like a,
a lot of people in special ops
and all those, he's kind of a,
he would call himself on a firearms
enthusiast. I call him a gun nut.
He's definitely a gun nut. But if you
had a bunch of dudes that were like,
really, I'm really good at
killing people like this.
And you just brought in 20 of them,
they shut up, shut the entire city down.
Absolute like,
where was this dis on Hollywood boulevard.
Now this is in north Hollywood.
What's happening here?
How come we're not seeing
anybody? Shouldn't that anybody
yet? It's guys are lazy.
Come on man. Okay, here it goes.
So now there he's just
running and shooting at cops.
Right?
I love these.
It's wolf blitz or reporting on the news.
We'll throw it and we're its way
here and see what happens. Oh,
that's Tom Wolf Blitzer. Uh,
obviously an a was here on this one.
Sounds a little wolfish.
Yeah, definitely. Was
quite a radically possibly a wouldn't
suspect at this point. And uh,
we're keeping an eye on this right now.
Let me just take a quick look back
over to the right as the situation.
Yeah, I think that's dean. If
you've got a shot. I think so.
I think that guy is dead right? The guy
in the car. That's why he's rolling. Oh,
he's hurt.
I forget what happened,
but I remember the cops let him bleed
out and people were saying that, uh,
it was cruel that the cops didn't call
the ambulances and and have this guy
taking care of the risk, their own lives
to do so to get this guy to, oh wait.
Well he just took off
staple this thing shut.
Okay.
Like can a reason that John Wick movie?
Yeah. Yeah. Did you see that movie?
Yeah.
It's fucking good movie man.
I watched on a plane coming
back from Mexico this weekend.
It's a fucking bad ass movies. You see
loss road yet? No, that was the best.
Like as far as like action movie,
that was the best action movie I've
seen in a long time. It was bad ass.
What's it called? John Wick. It's kind
of matrix. It was pretty good. Well,
it's not about the matrix at all.
It's about his hit man who these Russian
mobsters fuck with them and he decides
to go after them and kill them all.
It's just the gratuitous violence
level is off the fucking chain.
You got to check it out like murders
that counter Reeves does in this movie.
It's insane.
I mean I've never seen the guy killed
more people in a movie and do it.
It was fun to watch like the
way he was doing it was bad ass.
It was all most believable, you know,
like the way they had it set up,
everything that was like
really tight quarters.
It wasn't like a retard wagon train.
When they have a bunch of guys coming
out and somehow or another he managed to
survive. You kind of buy it pretty much
every step of the way. Like you know,
there's not a real person who
is that accurate with a gun.
But if it's a video game, you
know this, this could be possible.
There was no scene where you
go, it doesn't, how is it
going to get out of this?
It was one, there was one. They
kind of gave you a way out.
The kind of made sense. Good
enough. Good enough. Cause the,
the gratuitous violence and the action
teens really make you want to go be a
hitman. You want to just go
fuck people. It's a fun movie.
It's a wild fucking movie.
I heard the Jurassic Park movie sucked.
I heard it was okay. Yeah, but I, it looks
good. I, I'm sure I heard it was dumb.
Do you see it? I saw it. It's really
fun. Do you like everything though?
It's trying to take funds. Last thing you
don't like. Ah, I see plenty of movies.
I don't like getting one pitch perfect.
Two loves it. Loved it. Five to six hours.
One uh, no I did not hurt. It
was hard. It was enjoyable.
But I wanted to say what you were
talking about the twin towers before the
drastic world movie cause
it's in three d imax.
They showed the trailer for this
new movie with Jason Joseph.
Gordon Levitt about this French,
a tight rope walker that went between
the twin towers in the 70s and eight
recreated 1974 Manhattan.
Whoa.
We created the twin towers and it looked
awesome. It freaked the shit out of you.
I'll show you a picture.
Is it all CGI?
Oh goodness.
Gravity s kind of
recreation of this whole scenario.
Just the like where the
trailer starts out. I want
to ruin it for you. Even now.
You need to see it because it was awesome.
I know. I need to see it right now.
Have show that shit.
Fuck.
Or imax. It's three D as
well. That's quite all right.
All right. I can get the idea.
This is insane. It's so cool.
What they can do right now with CGI,
unless that's on a window washers,
cart, but just shooting it up to the top.
It's the trade center. It's gone, right?
Yeah. Good point. So this is all fake.
It's amazing. Come on. That's
incredible. That's all fake.
Oh my God.
My fucking heart hurts.
That view is insane.
Oh my God.
I'm literally freaking out
and my hands are sweating.
My toes won't stop twitching.
He's killed.
So He's standing on top of the twin
tower and you get to see what the fucking
drop looks like in homeboy is now
standing on an I beam poking out over the
edge. I don't think I can watch this.
Can you might do this in three Oh my God.
I can't even imagine what I'm seeing.
My own face.
This man, his balance. That's,
Oh, is it Jesus Christ? Boy,
I'm having a really hard
time watching him. Fuck.
That has to be like one of the
freakiest. Oh, you son of a bitch.
He's standing on one foot. What do you
mean a yoga master? Cagle oh my God.
In Three d and Imax Three D.
Ah,
that's why I want a trailer.
The walk.
How crazy is that? That we give a fuck
that he died, died. Did he? Does that?
I mean,
if he walked a tight rope and that type
rope was six inches off the ground,
you would not give a shit. Nope.
No one would see it. Sweaty palms.
But because he is a hundred stories up,
you know that he's fighting every
single instinct, every natural instinct.
The body has to get the
fuck away from danger.
Fuck that notices in the French guy.
Is it that they did doc documentary
a few years ago back? Yeah. Okay.
It's the same movie.
Yeah.
It was a documentary about this guy that
had the footage of him fought from afar,
but I didn't want to start a
recent one with the family. Those,
the family where the one guy with a
lenders, is that what they are? One,
one of them died and they still do it
like the mother and the son did it and
they passed each other on the
rope. What the fuck man? You know?
I mean what kind of a way to make a
living is that I think you find out I'd be
pissed
at my dad if that's what he did.
Now I got to follow in your footsteps.
How good do you think you could get? Do
you ever think you could get good enough?
Like maybe it's just us.
Maybe we look at that and go,
look, man, it ain't hard. It's
just we don't know how to do it.
You know what I mean? Right. Like
if, if, if you got really good,
can you get good enough to a point where
you could walk on one of those things
with 100% certainty that you're not going
to fall? Is that possible? Because look,
if I got, if I made you a
road across the Grand Canyon,
but the road was only
as wide as this table,
I could walk it and I would not like it.
I'd freak out the entire way.
I try to stay calm,
but if there's no wind and I knew that
the road was his as wide as this table,
I'm 100% confident that I'd be able to
suck it up and make it to the other side.
When I got to the side, I'd
probably be like, what the fuck?
I'd probably be freaking out. How
long do you think it would take? Yeah.
I don't know how far the the walk is.
How far is the walk?
I wouldn't rush it a couple of
hours. I wouldn't rush it. Yeah,
you wouldn't walk fast. I would not.
No, I would not. I would be fucking,
I'll do it as a meditation.
I would try to concentrate entirely on
my breath and each footstep and just keep
my balance good and stay calm.
You put a table like I could get in this
fucking table right now and I would,
I'll tell you right now,
never fall.
I will never fall standing up on this
table if, unless I slip on something.
You know what I'm saying? But if I'm
standing on this table right now,
there's no way this is a flat
thing. It's very wide. I'd be fine.
And I could walk across the table with
what certainty. Oh, 100% certainty.
Unless there's something really wrong
with my body or I'm that fucking drunk.
If I had a gamble,
I would be 100% certain that I could
walk across the length of this table.
But if you made it a mile long and
you put it over the Grand Canyon,
that's where shit gets weird.
You think you'd have to sit down at some
point cause you're like freaking out
maybe. But at the point is that
anybody can walk on this fucking table.
We all know how to walk.
Do you think you can get good
enough at walking on a tight rope?
That it's almost like this table,
you know,
as far as like the probabilities,
but someone can, right.
I mean there has to be someone out there
like if you watch those Cirque de Solei
fuckers, they can do shit that doesn't
seem like she'd be able to do it.
They can do stuff with their bodies.
Like I saw one guy and
he was pressing one guy.
The other guy was doing a handstand
with one hand holding this guy's hand.
So this guy's got a hand and another guy's
doing a handstand and maybe they were
using two hands and they were holding,
the guy was doing a handstand on the
other guy's hands. They're standing up,
it's fucking ridiculous. Who the fuck
do you know that you can do that?
Does anybody know anybody
that can do that? No.
Unless you know a Cirque de Solei
dude or a Cirque de Solei Gal,
but even they fuck up every now and then
like one dropped a at the MGM couple of
years ago, right? Wasn't
it? It's super risky. You're
watching that Cirque de Solei.
Yeah, I've seen it. I just went to like
a local circus in the middle of a field.
I took my son last week and these people
are in that with no wires and shit.
Like what the fuck are they doing
there?
Earn and son.
There's about, yeah. What did it get?
There's like there's like a hundred of
them and it doesn't only like 30 people
in the crowd. I'm like, what are
these people getting paid? Yeah,
they're doing two shows.
The next show has like a hundred people
going from town to town and they're
swinging off these ropes. I'm like,
it's a weird middle. Make a living man.
But that was like the Carney was like the,
there was a classic character in like
movies and stories and most people knew
about the traveling people that would go
from town to town. And these carnival,
there's set up carnivals, they're
all dangerous and shit and carnies.
I mean that's a classic description,
right? That's kind of fucked up.
And these guys looked at the guys that
worked at definitely, they all did, right?
Yeah. Even, yeah. Even last
week they look creepy. Well,
you remember those fucking
machines they would set up like we,
they had carnivals, Massachusetts. We
would go to these local places, you know,
they'd be set up seasonally
and something like that.
And you'd go down there and
they'd have fried dough,
you know that fried dough
with the fucking, the uh,
powdered sugar on it. Yeah.
What's that called? Watson? No, no.
Waffle cakes. Fun. Okay. Funnel cakes.
Elephant here. Yeah, there's a, there's a,
there's a zip something, a fucking Italian
name. Pour it. Dave gamble, you know,
or something like that. That's not it,
that it starts with a z. But anyway,
the point being this fried dough,
these stands and these,
and then they'd have these
ridiculous carousels.
Like what kind of an
asshole do you have to be?
Get on that and risk your life on this
fucking contraption that was put together
by these guys.
You know,
what kind of regulations do they
had for carnivals back then? Yeah,
it does not an inspector coming in every
day when they're shutting it off to
make sure it's safe. I know little town
that they're in. It's just such a weird,
like common thing. It's a common
thing. I carnivals are common.
Everybody knows about carnivals.
But to have that kind of a show,
go travel from town to
town, set up, put up tents,
put on little weird shows.
Try to get everybody's money and
then get the fuck out of dodge.
Move onto the next place.
All jaded and weird. Yeah,
cause every move you make a hit too.
For $200 you could sit two rows up and
on the doll over here, ride the cab.
Me and my son ride the camel for seven
bucks a piece. He wrote the [inaudible],
we were on a cattle together.
He wrote the elephant for nine.
That was nine and stuff. Yet they have
elephants, that program for two bucks.
That's a fucked up thing that
the circus animals like the,
do you ever see the one with the bear
and the monkey where there's a train bear
and a monkey and they're riding
bikes together? Never seen that.
It's pretty funny. Pretty fucked up.
The bear, um, crashes into the Monkey.
The monkey falls,
the bear crashes into them and the bear
decides amongst Assholey so kills him in
front of everybody.
He was in pain and he associated the
pain with this monkey fucking up, right?
Like he, like, I think he might've
thought the monkey attacked him.
Like that's why I fell like
this. My thought, like the
monkey was attacking him.
So He, this monkey in front of everybody
and they're trying to get them off the
monkeys. A fucking giant train. Grizzly
bear just like it's so, it's such a,
it's such a hilarious video. It's
horrible. Right? But it's also hilarious.
Like what the fuck is wrong with people?
You got to train.
Bear and a trained monkey. Look at this.
They're riding a bike together. I mean,
that is a real fucking bear. Oh
Shit. That's a real bear. That, look,
this guy falls down, the bare falls.
The bear knocks into this guy and so he,
he gets back on. Is that it already? Yes.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh. I missed it then. I fucked
up. I didn't see where the monkey had him.
I was too busy laughing.
It's just so crazy that people think it's
okay to get a bear to write a fucking
bicycle with a monkey. So, okay,
so there's a monkey in front of them
and the bears behind them. Okay.
I sit it and see, because the guy
got in the way right here. Boom.
The guy kind of fucked up and the bear
runs over the monkey and just decides to
Maul Him. Fuck this biding
bikes, socks. I'm a bear.
And these guys,
they can't do shit about it.
They're watching him tear this fucking
monkey apart. Nothing they could do.
Okay.
And then they realize like, Jesus Christ,
we're working with a bear. You know,
you thought of them as Hank,
your coworker. This is my
buddy Hank. You know? Oh,
Hanks a murderer. Thanks a fucking
murderer. No, no. He's a good guy.
He's a good guy and let's
crashes into you with a bike.
He just eats you in front of crowds.
It reminds me of days,
had a famous bet about Siegfried
and Roy. He's like, you know,
people just bought those tickets every
night. Cold tonight. Could be the night
that they don't have a
one of those anymore.
They don't have a CIG
Freedom Roy type act anymore.
I can't think of one famous thing in Vegas
like that. They still have the lines.
Apparently at the MGM, the PM GM has
lions and the barrage as dolphins.
It's kind of fucked. Then they take that
exhibit of the line exhibit out of the,
I don't know the damn. Yeah, I
don't remember seeing it in the day.
They took it out. That's good. I went
to it a long time ago and I was like,
what in the fuck didn't want him to get
attacked in there? In front of this.
One of the trainers got attacked. Yeah,
there's a video of that. I saw that,
but the idea that you could
have a fucking casino in Vegas.
Yeah,
and inside this glass box is
these port tigers or lions rather.
They are getting tortured and they're
looking at these people walking around
staring at them. That's way more
unnatural than a zoo plus cigarette smoke.
Cigarettes drink. Yeah. Gotcha.
Screaming. Yeah, of course. Yeah.
That's a fucked up place for a lion.
Why do people have lions in the back
of their Lamborghinis and do Dubai's a,
is that a real thing that people do?
You're talking about that dude is
driving the AMG Mercedes and he has a a a
leopard and his front seat.
It was a cheetah, I think
it was a cheetah actually.
Why did they do that?
They do that cause did my a tiger.
Why did Mike Tyson own those,
those crazy animals?
There's a documentary on
it that's really good.
It's called the elephant
in the living room,
and it's all about people that
keep these crazy exotic pets.
And this one guy that had lions and the
lions lived in a small box cart that
chat live Persian Gulf. Ah, Persians,
look at him. He's the most gangster. He's
hanging out with like, Whoa, Whoa, whoa,
Whoa, whoa. Scroll up.
He's hanging out with the lions
and they're covered in blood.
What the fuck are they covered in?
Blood for the dead animal right there.
Oh Jesus. So he would give them
that while they killed that thing.
So it gave them a calf.
They the mall, the calf,
and he comes in and sits next to the
body and hangs out with them. Oh my God.
They gave him a shark to kill.
This guy seems awesome. The well, there's
always going to be people like this.
Whenever there's billions of
dollars out there. Look at that.
The guys on a Mercedes, an AMG
Mercedes, and they standing on the roof,
which is an asshole thing to do.
And he's feeding his lion who was on the
hood of the car and his friends at the
driver's seat and it's fed. It's like
you've gotta be fucking kidding me, man.
This is going to be the best
youtube video. This guy's nuts.
This seemed like one dude.
So is he like training these lines?
I think it's just bad ass.
I probably fucks them.
That's his Instagram account.
That's hilarious. He's got money.
Look at that fucking one on a top
with a, hold on. Go back to that one.
Look at that shit. That is so
crazy. You got off my car. He's,
he's on his knees like on his toes.
Bent down like a rapper.
Like if he's playing dice or something
and right next to him as a lion and he's
on a Mercedes,
that's gotta be,
that's gotta be his dating profile for
whatever online services on Tinder or
whatever. That's his dating profile. Me.
I love nature and Mercedes Benz.
He's sucking my Dick. Yeah, that's,
Oh, such a ridiculous photo.
What does, you know, how's it
guy like that live in this world?
It's just,
I love that.
If you're going to have people
that are flashy and any way,
you're always gonna have that one person
takes flashing as to the most fucked up
place. So like whenever you have a
house that's like the most, the huge,
just be like,
what was the one that we were looking
at the other day that was in Bel Air?
That was 50, but that was
after the show was over. Right?
We out $500 million in Belair and the,
the previous most expensive
ones sold in Bel Air.
It was like a hundred million
dollars. Right? What the fuck? Really?
Like how come you don't retire?
Why do you have a $500 million house?
That's ridiculous. So yeah, this guy's
good thing that's got a, her pool.
So that's what the guy was in Dubai.
Yeah. So you get all these Russian checks,
European checks go over to Dubai.
I tried to find rich guys. Oh yeah,
yeah. When we were, uh,
I was in Abu Dhabi for the UFC and a bunch
of the guys went to Dubai just to see
what it was like and go
get some food and shit.
And they said that they walked into a
bar that had no idea and it was literally
all Russian hookers, the
entire bar. They're like, dude,
I think this is a hooker bar.
Like it was all Russian hookers
waiting for guys who show up.
And they got there and I say Russian,
but you know,
Middle East or eastern bloc country
type accents. And they were like,
I've never seen anything like it.
Like there's so much money
there apparently that they just,
that's just where they go.
They know that rich people are coming in
to vacation and they have certain spots
where they can just find
these Russian bronze.
Then there's also a bunch that come over
from eastern Europe and they just try
to find American men
and the move to America.
Did you ever think about doing
that? Absolutely. Okay. A Nice,
nice 10 from Siberia. Yeah. I mean I got,
I got some bedrooms in my house. Yeah.
Come on, stay, stay around,
get your green card.
I've had friends who bring them
back at a hotel like, oh yeah,
you know I got two mansions, I live
here, I live here and you know,
and then bang them and then try to get
rid of him after it. They got nothing.
Eventually if they keep doing that
they'll, they'll find a guy. Oh yeah,
absolutely. But the buys really
weird. Like that's where you,
if you kiss someone in public,
I get thrown in jail and stuff like that.
So he really got to do,
you can't do it in the bar,
you can't even do it on the till.
You get back to in the hotel room.
Well there was caught with Melatonin.
She got caught with Melatonin,
which is a natural supplement that helps
you go to sleep and they locked her in
fucking jail. She was an executive
at a sound, I think end the mall.
Like one of those.
I'm one of those production companies
and it was another lady or another guy
rather that got arrested for having some
prescription medication that's illegal
there but not illegal in the UK where
he lived and so he had some prescription
medication then he travels with,
but he has to take,
his doctor prescribes it and they
fucking locked him right in jail.
They took his,
took his medication away from him and
through him in a box yet I was a rapper
too going over, cause they do a lot of
constant over there. Rapper had some,
I think he had some marijuana. I'm just
a little, he got thrown in jail. Porto,
Carrie Bradshaw.
She kissed that guy on the
beach and they've got arrested
in sex in the city too.
I S I did not see that. Is that a
movie dead more than one movement?
No, I did not. We talked about it.
Sex and the city too. Yeah. No,
we definitely did not talk about it.
I've never seen a city to kiss Mr
big on the beach and they can see it.
I watched some of the previews.
I think we might have mocked it,
but we never talked about me seeing it.
Oh, I was in, let them talk about it.
There was, there was actually a second
one. If I saw it, I would talk about it.
You liked we you'd like so retarded.
I know.
You really should go to a doctor. The
patch did something. Tell him. Yeah,
he's something wrong with your brain.
Like half your sentences today are
so goofy. That three. That's exactly
what you were saying. It's like you're
off. I could feel it. Oh yeah, I miss her.
It's totally, I feel you're going
to make it. No, you're so weak. No,
I will make it.
She's a man up man up hungry
right now. I'm, I don't,
I'm not normally Hungary
and so it's like weird.
I had something that they say like that's
a big one with cigarette smokers that
the appetite suppressant aspect of it,
it's 100% like I never wanted to eat
like at one in the after World War Two in
the afternoon or whatever and I
well you got to replace it with something
else. You obviously have an addiction,
so you've got to get a new healthy
addiction. That's what you gotta do.
Okay.
As start calling it a jam or something,
you know?
Hmm.
Yeah. I'd been drinking Jamba juice
lately though. That's good. Fruit juice
to start. Yeah. That's not bad. The
problem with Jamba juice, not Jamba juice,
but like a lot of those places
you think you're getting,
I'm going to have a smoothie. The amount
of sugar that's in those smoothies,
it's a lot of divisions. Juice and
yeah. Really? When you have an orange,
you supposed to eat an orange,
like orange juice is kind of an unnatural
way to get orange stuff. You know,
to have this such a concentrated amount,
like when you,
you were drinking orange juice,
the way that it comes into your body,
your body's like,
how the fuck did you get this?
Like this I talked to was not in the
orange. Why are you not chew and fiber?
This isn't attached to the pulp and all
that other stuff. Like how'd you do this?
And you're just pouring it
right in your bloodstream.
It's just basically like sugar water.
It's better for you. Like fresh squeeze,
a lot of vitamins in it and stuff,
but there's a lot of sugar.
A lot of calories and fruit juices.
Yeah.
Try to fresh juice or mega right there.
Don't give him advice for free. He's
not gonna. He's not gonna know it.
I used to juice.
He's already thinking about the cigarette.
He's going to have it in
his car on the way home.
I knew I was going to stop at the
gas station and like, fuck it man.
It's crashed this mother
fucker right into the beach.
It's important to when you doing
out in La what's going on? Yeah.
What are you doing? Did you know the usual
meetings? What I tell you? Great. Yeah.
We're gonna put you in a movie and we've
got a part for you and Adam Sandler.
I'll probably call you tomorrow at home
and then you never hear from again.
You know one of those sometimes
those pan out. Yeah, once in a while.
I do actually. So that's what you're
out here and I do some standup shows.
I think you're going to do a show
together at the comedy store and Brian,
you're doing that show to right. And
Joey has just got added to it. GDS,
Delray says
belly room show to folks. So uh, don't
sleep. It's the only seats like 70 people.
It's only supposed to see 70 people I
already sold out. Yeah, it probably is,
but it's a, they really jam like 90 in
that right? We think somewhere in there,
somewhere on there.
Maybe the fire marshal doesn't know.
Apparently supposed to get 57
57. I loved that. Roam the
belly room markets the best.
I got to go there tonight and check to
make sure the sound system is still there
cause I wasn't working last night.
I think they might've blown her
new speakers up there. Oh No.
So anybody can use it, right?
People that unfortunately, yeah,
there's not a sound guy up in there.
It's kind of like I said,
most comedy clubs you usually
a sound guy that takes
care of, of the sound board and
everything and the belly room.
It's kind of like whoever's running the
show kind of takes over the sound word,
which is a horrible idea. But so you
guys put in a new sound board? Yeah.
Kill Tony. The one episode you can
just raise money. No idea. It was a,
that was a standup show or
I did death squad showed up,
put all the money towards it and
then the comedy store matched it.
So we got it like our really high end
sound system up there and some of them
might have blown it. Maybe on, I'll
find out tonight or this weekend too.
I'm there Friday and Saturday.
I'm doing the belly room. Yeah.
We have killed Tony Tonight there.
So I get to
put a new sound board on your Amazon gift,
a gift shop or whatever the hell it is.
Yeah.
So uh, you don't start before, right?
Yeah. What do you do mostly in New York,
which uh, which clubs do you work
at? Does a new club called the stand?
You'll keep hearing good things
about that for a club. Yeah.
Ari does that place a
lot? Yeah, it's, yeah,
it's similar to the comedy cellar
downstairs in our basement.
Upstairs you're hang the comex.
Great food. Um, I did add, you know,
in the comedy cellar, standup New
York, still the good road gigs around.
They're still not really not in that area.
His governor still around.
Governors is still there. It's a great
gig. That's a great gig brokerage.
The Braemar brokerage is still the isle.
I used to have a hard time getting
booked there cause I was dirty.
So I worked at one time
and the guy hated me.
The guy who originally owned it and I
never went back after that. The governor,
they didn't care. No. Devin is it like,
they just wanted you to be funny, but, uh,
the brokerage, they wanted it squeaky
clean. 1970s Johnny Carson style.
This is a bunch of those clubs.
Well, that's comedy Magic Club.
Joey Diaz still can't work the comedy
and Magic Club. They won't, they,
they had to have a conversation with me
about Joey because Joey was my opening
act. You know, I always brought Joey
with me as much as I can. And, uh,
comedy Magic Club. We're like, we have to
talk to you about this. It's like, well,
isn't that weird though, that they let
Ari shift fear? He's not as dirty as Joey.
He used to be pretty fucking dirty.
I remember the weekend that
that's a different level.
It's a different level with
Joey's doing the pigeon,
you know you're doing that
eating a monkey from behind.
You're sticking your nose right
now, asshole. Like a page.
And I think it goes like this. He goes,
that's a chicken, but what the fuck?
You know what I'm talking
about the pigeon? Yeah.
He was just doing some crazy ass
eating stuff and uh, Mike is like,
that's it. Because that was also
back before, like there was,
the shows would be packed,
but half the people would know
me from like maybe fear factor.
And he had a bunch of regulars that would
go there every Sunday no matter what,
every weekend, no matter what. He's
got a bunch of like regulars and he,
he always has his squeaky clean shells.
So they would come to see me and they'd
have no idea what the fuck was about to
hit them. And Julie would get onstage
and a bunch of, I'm like barely,
barely made it through, almost had heart
attacks, ran out into the fucking street.
What did you do to me?
They're used to like the 9:00 AM uh,
Jay Leno show on Sunday, you
know, not, not really 9:00
AM, but it might as well be,
you know,
he would do these a tonight show monologue
says he we're working on on Sunday.
So yeah. And he'd go down there and just
read a bunch of like very non offensive,
very mild tonight show style jokes.
So they got used to that.
And then Joey Diaz just hits
the stage like fucking tornado.
They just didn't know what to do.
So half of them loved it,
but it was a good percent.
But now if we went back it would be 100%
they would know what the fuck to expect
that it would be awesome. But
he's scared. Yeah. I liked that,
that club once and I was a tonight show,
people coming to see me and they were
gave me a warning and they go, look,
I don't know why you're going
to do up here. I go, I'm
doing it tonight. Show side.
Yeah, it's four and a half
minutes. I can't do any dirty
shit on the tonight show.
It's going to be fine.
Like, all right, we'll just,
just make sure you know we don't,
we know you've got a reputation from
these codes from Howard stern and all this
stuff and how gross. I know I'm
auditioning for it tonight show.
I'm not going to talk about ass eating.
You'd have to really say it in a way
that it could get on. What year was this?
This was probably like eight years ago,
seven years ago.
They have lighter standards now,
like standards and practices that you
can get away with a lot of shit now that
you'd never could get away
with just a few years ago.
Like the Internet is opening
up the boundaries for what?
Like just look at the,
the Gore factor.
Look at like I was watching CSI and the
other day and they had some bodies that
they were like picking bullets out
of or some shit and I was like, whoa.
Like I can't believe this is regular TV.
Like really fucking gory.
They show it to you like really quick.
You know,
like they don't show you
like long focused shots,
but it's enough that you're like, Whoa,
I can't believe this is regular TV.
Do you think the fear factor episode
with the Com would be able to be passed
nowadays? No. Kent maybe be
drink Tom, someone's son,
someone's son, someone's daughter.
You're making them drink. Come on TV.
Every watched that.
The other day,
one of the grossest things I've
ever heard someone trying, oh,
they'd drink a big gulp full of cum,
big drink like 24 hours,
24 ounces rather. It was honest. It
didn't make the shell, no, never,
never got in the year in America,
but it made the air and like
Holland and a bunch of other cities,
so they took a bunch of the countries.
So they took the video of that and they
upload it to youtube. You could watch it.
It's available. It was the most
ridiculous. A shy girl drank guy,
one guy and two girls.
I said Craig,
did you see that new fear factor of rip
off Sir that's starting heard about it?
Yeah, it's pretty, pretty close. Good.
They even advertise it in the
commercial like juice, like fear factor,
bullseye or whatever. Really they say just
like fear factor. Wow. That's hilarious.
Yeah man, that was a show with, that was
one of the rare times in life where uh,
someone got fired because someone
drank come on TV. Cause that was,
that was what happened.
We all got fired because someone drank
come on TV and I was happy. I was like,
good. It's canceled. Like I was
literally happy that it was cancerous.
Why to show got canceled.
The other ratings were really good.
It was doing really
well when it came back,
the, the stunts were insane, but the
stunts were getting fucking hairy.
Like we had a couple,
like pretty pretty big accidents.
There was one where this couple left,
like the um,
the driver or something happened and
his windshield was obscured with like a
cardboard box and they almost crashed
into this lady's leg. Like it was,
it was enough that I was like,
Whoa,
like you guys are taking
some fucking chances here.
Like there was always a certain
amount of chance in fear factor,
but they were taking some
trances that I was like,
what happens if this goes wrong?
Like one of them was you were attached
to a Bungee cord that was attached to a
helicopter and you had to,
that your partner had to unlock you.
So there's a like a chain full of keys
and then there's a lock and so you have
to find the right lock.
So it's you and you're competing with
someone else and there's helicopters and
the helicopter has a hold
of you on a Bungee cord.
I pulled tight and then so when
they let go, when they unlock you,
they let go and you go shooting
off into fucking space shit.
And I'm saying like they were
falling through the air full,
flying through the air.
On the most crazy bungee cord you've ever
seen you in life and it's attached to
a fucking helicopter. So you
watching this, you're like,
what if the helicopter crashes?
Like has anybody done this?
Like how many dry runs if
you'd done with this right?
Like you know the stunt guys,
they don't even get paid and they would
have to recreate this fucking thing and
a lot of times they would
recreate it with PA's.
They'd get a PA to do the stunt and they
would pay him like 100 bucks and then
they would attach them to this fucking
thing and the launched him into into
space or shit, how's he sung?
That's going to die. You can't,
there's no way you can prevent, like you
can't stop anything if it goes wrong.
There's no fee. Like if that Bungee
cord snaps, you're dead. Okay.
If the helicopter crashes, everyone's
dead. And they did it off a canyon.
Like there's like this like huge cliff
and the tree was attached to the people
and the edge of this cliff. Oh,
this is it right here. Yeah.
Somebody who's running the,
the fear factor Facebook page.
And making all these look, look at this
shit. Shit. Backed that up a second.
So just, you can see how retarded that
is. Watched it. She gets the key in.
She unlocks it.
And the moment she does,
as soon as she gets free,
he pulls the I'm fucking thing.
Look at that thing.
She got shot through the fucking
air on the bottom of a helicopter.
So ridiculous.
That Lady Shave your head to that was,
that was more disturbing for
people than anything else.
He made that lady shave her hair.
She shaved her head.
Didn't you make somebody get a tattoo
also? No, they did. They wouldn't do it.
They quit.
They did.
They had to get a fear factor tattoo
and the Tattoo of me really? Yup.
And that, that got approved
by NBC, which is ridiculous.
And as they wanted to do at
the bottom of their feet,
but can't do it because of um, uh,
sanity, you know, hygiene reasons.
When you step on,
if you have a sore
like that at the bottom
of your foot at risks,
pretty severe infection
possibilities. But, um, they did that,
that,
that NBC said they could have the tattoo.
And the other thing that NBC said
was that they could drink piss.
They drank piss too.
They drank donkey pis and donkey come
or was cow piss and donkey Kong. Yeah.
Yeah. That was real calm.
Was that in their donkey come
who's real calm? Like, oh,
the producers and the line,
everybody's, everybody on the street.
We just pull over and ask people to
jerk it off. It was so ridiculous.
It was such as huge vat
of calm that they had to,
they would pour into these glasses.
And here's the thing,
like your best case scenario in this game,
the best you could do,
you would have to drink five ounces.
Absolutely.
Absolutely have to drink five ounces
because they're playing horseshoes.
So if you fucking got a ringer, you nailed
it. You didn't, it's not even, you know,
like if you nail it, you don't have
to drink now. Even if you nail it,
you have to drink five ounces.
Just crazy.
Was it refrigerated or was it like
water temperature now you'd have to
refrigerate it. Didn't want to serve
that shield. Yeah. That's how I feel.
At least you could pretend it's something
else. If it's hot, it's going down.
You throw it, you know exactly what it
is. They get a latte. No little hot latte.
That's bad. I don't know what
you're putting in your locked eyes.
What do you need to stop right now
or are you going to get pregnant?
It's just like the Kelly.
You want to chill. That's a
lot easier going down. Chill.
It's all psychological though
cause it's like it's come right.
It's salty liquid like not
like when you swallow snot.
It's all psychological,
but the actual taste of Snot,
it's not the worst thing in the world.
You know?
I'm sure there's a lot of things to taste
way better than way worse than snot or
com. But a check that
swallows got a big advantage.
He's like girl saying that the girls,
it was hilarious. They were like,
I'll take the comp. The girl took the calm
over the pissed. I go, really? She goes,
yeah, what's the big deal? I was
like, wow, what a trooper. You know,
like she took the come, she's like, it'd
be easier. I've swallowed come before.
We didn't have any of that
on TV obviously, but they
were laughing about it.
You're like, I've swallowed before, this
will be easy. Fine. And I was like, wow.
Like I guess a guy would probably like
if there was some sort of a squirting
thing that pigs did and you could collect
that and a guy had to choose between,
uh, drinking that stuff
or a, or something else,
you would go with the squirty stuff.
Cause it's like,
it's coming out of a girl's vagina. It's
just, just like, girl come, no big deal.
What was it?
The girl.
But I think that's how the girls looked
at it when they thought about this.
The idea. Yeah, that's common dude.
Oh my God.
They drank a mug.
You girls are awesome.
Like I was plugging in. They're plugging
their nose while they're drinking.
Come look at that guy, chuck. Come,
that guy just chugged.
Come. Oh my goodness.
Okay. Well how has that fear, so fear
factors released that then? Oh No, no.
If it's edited, it's fear
factor moments. Yeah, it's,
it's something happened about
six months ago. Fear factors.
Facebook page just started posting brand
new videos and like you advertisements
and stuff. He goes to shit that come
out. I love how Joe's right in her face.
Come on, fucking do it already. A trooper.
I still to this day I'll go back and
I watched this and I can't believe it
really happened.
Didn't you have a guy named Brian that
tested everything before that they had to
test it? No, there was a
bunch of guys. But Josh, Josh
Silverman, he was the, well,
he was the beast done. Um,
producer. He produced it.
He had done a bunch of
different crazy shows. He's out.
He actually had been on a reality show.
He's on Ted Nugent's reality show at one
point in time as a contestant. Rarely,
but that guy was nuts and he was
[inaudible]. He was getting dark.
Like his mind was getting
very dark from all of the, uh,
coming up with the different
stunts for these people.
Like figuring out different ways
to get people to fucking pull, uh,
like bison hearts out of a
swimming pool filled with blood.
Like they kept coming up with more and
more fucked up things and I was like,
this is gotta be bad for your brain.
Like to ha like this is your job.
And he was like, totally. It's definitely,
it's not good. Yeah. It was like this not,
it's not good to think about
this kind of stuff all the time.
That's why they came up with
this drinking come thing I think.
I think they got so lost,
they didn't realize like how insane this
is going to be to the rest of the world.
Like they were like, look gay. They
gave us the green light. Let's do it.
We're gonna push the envelope.
It was pushed you off. All right,
we're going to do lunch on Tuesday and
like the network and the executive would
high five each other. They,
they're so out of touch.
They had no idea that the rest
of the world was going to go.
You make people drink, come
on TV, even drinking piss.
Like they just making people drink.
Pisses is probably enough
to get the show canceled,
but the fact that there was pissed and
come together, the network is like,
what did we do?
What happened here?
They should bring it back but put on
Netflix friends censored and make it like
the grossest of gross. Well,
I'm not doing it. I'm done.
Like eating yeast infection.
I'll never do it again.
A kit we can you see a yeast infection
would have totally creamy. Oh No,
it's cream. It goes to the same in
Grecian comes out, he's scooping,
scooping it up like it's like he's making
pizza or I've had this hurricane doe
chunky.
You've had a curdled.
I mean I've put on my deck and it's been
like chunks of white east all over it.
Yeah, that's not good. Again,
the quality of the company that you
keep out as reflected in many shitty
decisions that you've made in this
crazy life. What's wrong with you? Boy,
she had diabetes, she had diabetes
and that affects your vagina. Oh yeah.
You get yeast infections all day.
That makes sense.
I guess your whole body is out
of whack. They say a lot of, um,
lot of issues that people
have with various bacteria
levels and things like that.
You could be mitigated with
just probiotics that people
took probiotics, all the,
it'd be less
ease. Infections, like a lot of
less, lot less, uh, bacterial issues.
Yeah. A lot of aloe drink
an ally. Do you, uh,
do you eat healthy Jim
Florentine probiotics every
day? You look healthy as, fuck,
I just lost 25 pounds. Did you? Yeah.
What'd you do? Why not juice fast? Well,
I got a divorce so that, that
helps. That helps. Yeah. 13 days.
No food. Comics with the
divorces, that's rare.
Usually it works out and it dies.
I know.
It's like when a comics happily married,
he goes, you okay, what's wrong with him?
Is he all right on that
for dicey is still fun.
Just came to my wedding and he goes,
first of all, he goes, look, he goes,
I look at all your friends here.
He goes to roll a bunch of fucking creeps.
I don't know where they've come by, where
these people work. He goes here, take us.
He just handed me a wad of cash.
He goes,
I'm not even going to leave an envelope
because somebody is gonna steal it.
Put this in your pocket now and
that he wishes. He goes, look,
you're wife's lovely and this
is a great day for you guys,
but just know one day she's
going to hate your guts.
So he was right.
Did they think,
did I, you're a wild man.
You're always doing stand up.
You keep crazy friends. Did you date
girls and think they could change you?
Is it one of those things where like
he's a smart guy, he's really nice.
I just think that if I just
get a hold of we, you know,
we'll work it out now because I
always want to have to the crazy ones.
I never went after a normal one. It
probably showed of that party might. Nah,
I mean, you know, no, I didn't
always like that. The wild ones.
So they weren't looking to tame anybody.
How do you find a normal person? Yeah.
You can't even find a normal personality.
Normal people are not going to find
you, first of all, where are you going?
You're going to the comedy store, you're
going to a bar. It's just hanging out at,
at apple on weekends off,
you know they work nine to five
and you're working weekends.
You never get to see,
um,
that's when they want to hang with
their friends and go to like fucking
Applebee's or some shit.
The all around as a comic,
your hours are so fucked and your
lifestyle so crazy that unless the girl is
living some sort of a
crazy life of her own,
she's not going to
understand like a stripper.
That's why they have the same
hours. Exactly. Well a lot
of comics went up, Danes,
strippers for a bunch of reasons,
but that's a big one of them is just that
some girls like you're out every night.
Like I've had friends that I've lost.
Like they don't do standup anymore
because their wife could upset.
They were out two months doing stand up
and if you gotta if you're gonna be a
good comic, you have to work a lot. You
have to work every week. You have to,
I mean, you might be able to
take weeks off here and there,
but essentially you're
working several days a week,
every week and you're doing it at night
and you've got a right and you've got to
work on new shit and you've
got to constantly be in
that zone and you've got to
go to the clubs. He got to, you
have to, if you don't do it,
you're not going to develop material.
Yeah. So if you're dating someone,
they're like, why do
you, I don't understand.
You're not even getting paid for this.
You're getting like $15 like fuck,
that is not, no, I'm working like, where
do you think these jokes come from?
They don't come from the fucking choke
fairy. Like these bitches need to grow.
I've got to go water.
The, you know, that's,
that's what you do. You go to the
comedy store on a Tuesday night,
you're watering the garden. So
the fuck you're doing. Yeah.
A lot of people can't get that concept
working for food or just not working at
all during the week though. Sets
they want to hang out, watch a movie.
It's Tuesday night TV
show and they're like,
you're going to go out there for free.
How many people are going to be
at for people? Is that worth it?
They don't get it.
Those conversations we used to be
so frustrating to me but I get it.
I get it in from the girls' point of view,
you know she wants a normal life.
People want a normal life.
They want someone who's going to be home
on no normal daytime hours that I want
some guys calling them from,
from the road cause he did ecstasy.
They want shit to be normal. I get it.
But strippers don't. So like if you're,
unless she really wants to settle
down and be normal and she's just,
she's in the last days of
stripping like this is it.
I'm almost 30 I'm so tired of this.
It's such bullshit.
He's roped me in one of those problem.
But you got a wild 24 year old, Jesus,
forget it and it, yeah. Jesus
Christ, him flying team.
So that's why I think cam
girls is the way they future.
Cause when you're out at the comedy club
they could be squirting and at home,
you know,
and then you just have like a,
you're still committed to that score
and thing. Um, it is p unproven. No,
it's been proven scientifically that
it's p they have actual studies now,
Tony Hinchcliffe makes fun of
you in his act actually wrong.
It's completely wrong because scientists,
Brian's here, ladies and gentlemen,
you get all the retarded shit.
He said during the past two hours.
Want to clear things up.
Now there's intelligence when
the knowledge of squirting,
when vice did the article
about squirting being p,
there's a lot of people did an article.
It's the same base thing
that even when we had,
what's his face in here the
other day, he even goes, no,
I get what you're saying there.
It's two different kinds of,
have you ever had sex with a
girl and after you're done,
there's a mungus water like spot on
your, on your blanket. Yeah. Right.
That's squirting. That's gushing. It's,
that's what I'm talking about. What,
what those reports are talking about
when it's shooting out, projecting.
That's p that's obviously P it's coming
out of the pee hole, but gushing,
gushing is what I'm talking
about and get some girls.
Some girls you can hit a certain part
of their g spot and you'll feel like a
flood come out and that is not
p and even Dr drew says it.
A lot of people even say
after drew says abductors,
you're also says pot is addictive.
He said that a long time ago.
Albums you let them go now
because you're on his side.
When it comes to squirting,
I think what it is,
he used to be anti Dr
drew when it came to weed,
but according to him is more important
than we'd squirting is his big foot.
He will fucking argue with you
if you tell him scoring out.
Real squirting is the loch ness monster.
Squirting is his UFO.
Who thinks squirting is cheesy, but
I can't make girl squirt. Yeah, dude,
you can't do it. No. You know, I mean,
I know how to get them to drink a
gallon of water and piss all over you.
You can feel it.
It's like when Jesus touches me,
I can't describe it bro.
I just feel it.
You'd saying every girl can squirt
like you can make any girls.
Most girls can square it. I think
they drink a lot of water. Hold it in.
Wait for Brian to finger on price.
It's what I'm saying is real,
but the UFO fanatic, it's, it's,
I think most guys I've had that experience
when you're with a girl and you're
like, Holy Shit, you were really
wet this time and you look down,
there's a huge wet spot. That's
what I'm talking about. Well yeah.
Girls have vaginal, vaginal
rather. Lubrication comes
out of their body sometimes,
but it doesn't ever score
it out. It doesn't our score
it out like on the video,
but girls are going like this is fucking
pissing all over the camera. Right.
That's, that's the
problem. That's, that's,
that's p obviously you like a slippery
politician have changed your stance. No,
I've never changed to say that
the spray was a different type.
I've never said it was different than
urine. I've never said that. Well,
the core basic, when you see something
squared, I got girls pee hole.
It's a last podcast where squirting was
discussed and Brian angrily yet again
defended the art of scoring. I've always
said the exact factors of squirting. No,
you definitely said recording. He's
real and now you're saying gushing term.
What you guys are calling it
squirting is in the business.
You know a lot of you like fucking
pedestrians. You have your terms.
I know your terms cording and as
pros we were first two is gushing.
It's gushing. Yeah, she was a gusher.
Right, and that's what, and that's what,
what's confusing, what people
think squirting is fake and stuff.
The people are confused. A lot of
things. When you have sex with a girl,
sometimes it's a little wet, right? But
there's sometimes where you could have,
you could feel it just pouring out of
her and it won't stop and she's all over
the place.
She's going to be like the wicked witch
of the West and Maltin you were to take
all that juice, throw it in a test tube
that's not p. Okay, decides this is Brian.
What if she go perform these tests? They,
I've heard many people talk about it,
including documentary,
talking about bring up some fun,
some facts doctor drew about squirting.
Go Google that.
I don't need to already know about
this a million times to calm then, Huh?
Yeah. It's a mixture of, no it's not.
But the scientists that have
studied it say it's p sorry,
but how do you know I can use a computer?
I just know I don't need no fancy science.
I don't have a companion
friend Jesus in my heart.
What would you mind if it was pay it
and that's it.
And that's another thing and that's
another thing is the story of this whole
conversation. And that's another thing
because I've actually had a girl,
gosh or squirt or whatever while I was
eating her out before and I grew up in
your mouth. It did not taste
like p because he knows
he's drinking a lot of P's.
Basically. The piece or Malia
it was, it was a mixture.
It was a measure that is his,
I mean,
cosmo Martinis,
the girls come is usually has a
hints of pee in it, but it's not,
it's not urine. Okay. And
what about Oak Tannins?
All the stuff that they find
from those aged barrels.
It gets bad. I'm not getting
mad. It's just like, dude,
definitely get upset when it comes to
the topic of squirting. You defend it.
Like it's a religious thing because
people are so confused about it.
Super confused.
It's a matter of fact is they're giving
a lot of university level courses on it
because there's so much confusion
about whether or not scoring is p no.
When you see it,
what you see him in porn is usually a
water that's been put up there or urine
like you said. But that's not
what I'm fucking talking about.
I'm talking about there's ways that you
can hit the g spot with your Dick and
make the girl. Gosh. Um, I dunno. I
don't think too many people bother.
I didn't even, they didn't squirt
even a little in the old point.
What are they doing differently? Do they
not know what they're doing back then?
Ron, Jeremy, Ron. Jeremy didn't know how
to lay some dick out. No, that's fake.
That's what I'm saying is fake.
What are you talking about?
I'm saying that the stuff that you see
in porn that you guys think is squirting
is water that has the guys you dummies.
That's like you so called Christians.
He's like a religious fanatic over there.
I don't think most people care.
You know, like yeah, you could go, you
know at district squirt it last night.
Like that's actually pay like Oh really?
And that's it.
Oh I know what that it was at my mouth.
All right, well whatever I drank pay,
I'll call that a collection. Some Gosh,
you didn't need it to the rubber gloves.
You got to need a chain of command, chain
of custody. You got to scrape it up.
You have to guide there in a sealed
envelope. Take it to the lab.
I don't know what the fuck you're gonna
do with it on the way to the airport.
Hopefully she doesn't have
a yeast infection at the
same time cause that's what
it makes sense with the
studies. Frothy. Gosh,
okay.
Definitely need to go back to smoking.
Cigarettes will tell you that. Why?
Because your brain, what happened
over the last few days. It's shocking.
But what I've been saying right now,
it's so accurate and
the fact that you were actually defending
squirting the fact that I could troll
you so hard that I could just,
it's just all I have to say,
it's squirting as p and you will
go into a fucking frothy panic.
Okay.
No, I'm not getting into a panic. I
just said people defensive. It's a,
it's an annoying when people go
to knowing when people on Twitter,
my Jesus squirting, it's not
real. And like it's like,
all right, well guess what?
The expired that's coming
your way today, Fella. I know.
What's your Twitter handle?
Red Band.
[inaudible] I gotta give you a lot
of fucking medical studies on pice.
Various properties of pissed. It's
gushing. Guys. Guys don't even know.
She's such amateurs. You don't
even know how to make a girl Gush.
Yeah.
So you can make every girl,
not every girl,
but I couldn't make a lot of lives
because of the shape of my Dick and like a
certain way. What's wrong with it?
It's pointed towards my debt, my face.
So it's kind of like bent
towards my face and a,
if you put your like a his legs
up between your shoulder and make
me throw up this podcast.
We're about to end soon.
So you've got to put it over your legs.
Yeah, usually over your shoulders.
Relax over. Yeah. And it's got a band up.
Well, I don't know if it has to bend up,
but I'm just saying that that's why
I think I've had such great success.
You should give seminars. I just
did. No, you just explained.
It should give seminars where you're
like, walk around people, tell him, nope,
your hips over here like a yoga class.
Wait down here or it looks at every
guy's deck. Nope, doesn't end up.
You got to break your Dick.
I could take your money,
but you're not going to be able to do it.
I know he's a young age.
You could just put it underneath your
belt buckle and it will grow that way
around your belly.
So every time you have a bone here,
just puts it straight up north.
He's 40 grown man.
That reminds me of a Brady
bunch episode where Bobby,
you want it to be taller so he hung
from the swing set was arms. Yeah,
cause he wanted to be taller. I
remember that episode. So that's what,
that's what I was pretty, but you're
going to stays up. Deli is a natural,
the Brady bunch and wasn't real.
And he's a real person.
You really fucking believe.
I really believe it's going to change
the shape of your Dick by tucking it in
your balls. You know what?
I'm wearing a belt right now.
I'm going to do around the
right, wrap it up, tie it or not.
Maybe you get one of those versus Florida.
And I'm looking for a squirter.
I've had some pretty good squirters. Okay,
buddy. All right, let's wrap this up.
Belly button. Thanks for showing
up. You're the best, Jim Florentine.
What's going on, man? Where's the,
where's the the, uh, website, uh,
what's a clarky.com and it's
Mr Jim Florentine on Twitter.
This is Jim Florence and a Twitter.
I'm going to be at Amy Schumer.
No movie coming up in July 17th.
It's a moving train wreck. Oh,
what is it? It's a comedy. Her
a movie with Judd Apatow direct.
I just got a little part in it.
Beautiful.
But I didn't get caught cause people
have seen it and said it. It's a good,
good scene. So excellent. Cool. And
then I just did it up. So Louie,
so nicely. Nice. And uh, you got
any comedy club dates coming up?
Just this Wednesday night,
Wednesday night comedy store,
be at the comedy store and
that ball at the Martha.
Hopefully mine will be smoking by then.
We get the old Brian back.
We'll take them to a doctor. All
right, I'll smoke. No, don't do it.
And I've got a podcast. Oh yes.
What is it? Comedy Metal midgets.
Jim Florentine and that'll midgets
or mental metal? Metal. Metal.
Midges yeah, those three things
in that order. Yeah. I just,
it had a nice ring to it.
Dude. I go, I forgot to talk
to you about this one. Dude.
Ask you off the air, but your
friend who uh, lives in Florida,
some crazy friend who was listening
to your radio show, Gary from Florida.
Is it the, the nutty dude? Yeah.
Fucks all these girls and has
all these ridiculous stories.
Fucks him in the ass person.
I cook some chicken Marsala and I
thought some of the gas you will,
you talking to him? Were you
talking about him? I don't remember.
It was on the radio show,
but I was fuck,
I sat in my car out here in this parking
lot was laughing like a mental patient.
I was just with him this past weekend.
He's insane.
He goes on these dating websites
and gets these girls. He, he started
when he was 35. He did, he put
in from 40 to 65 cause he goes,
no one at 35 wants to fuck those women.
I will.
It's like I'm not going
after a 22 year olds.
So some 52 year old and Florida
single, you know, big tits,
divorced, Tan, take about
one day. Take a look,
just feed me and fuck me was like
first night, right? And yes. Whoa.
Eight at a 10 times eight out
of 10 pain in his pen. Wow.
He looks like a bloated Tony,
Dan. So I'll let you know.
So it works for him. And he and a 35 year
old wants to the funk of 52 year old.
So he's got that market. That's smart.
Yeah. Oh yeah. He's always been like that.
Hey, leave a message. I just
fucked a 64 year olds. He goes,
she,
she was,
she wanted to be in bed by eight so I'm
going back out trying to get another one.
Oh my God. That's so bizarre.
That's a smart move though.
If you want numbers,
you want to put up numbers.
That's all he cared about
was numbers. He's like, look,
I got to get a hall of fame numbers.
It's all I'm looking for.
And these when we get attached to
him or they don't care, I want Dick.
It's Florida. They don't care. They
don't care. Cause Florida. Yeah, Florida.
It's a whole other animal down there.
They don't give a shit.
They moved from one to another
to another. Really? Yeah.
He might go see him one more time and
they don't even bother him after that.
Really. Especially an older woman, they're
just set in their ways. They're like,
look, I just want to get laid. Right.
I could get that like they
not looking for a man anymore.
Now it's come along and tell him what to
do. Yeah, they got luck, man. I'm horny.
It's been awhile. Wow.
A lot of times he what?
He tried to do it without even
getting dinner. He's like, let me see.
He tried to pull that one off.
Just meet him for a drink. Right.
He is a move was never to go,
let's meet at six it was always like
eight 30 so he didn't have to buy him
dinner. He's like, they're
definitely going to eat by then,
so he had his strategy. Yeah, Gary,
I mean you're banging her in the ass the
first night you probably could buy or a
dinner. It's worth it.
It's worth $150 dinner.
Was he because he didn't want to take a
chance of being stuck at dinner or was
he trying to save money,
save money and just be complete dirt bag?
That's the only reason cause you'd get
stuck in a horrible conversation if you
commit to dinner and as you just met this
person and like five minutes into the
conversation and realize they're
fucking crazy. Like, oh no,
I'm going to have a meal
with this person. Shit. Yeah.
Then you just got to find the waiter.
I'll be right back.
You'll find the waiter give the waiter
money and you'd get the fuck out of dodge
before they even know what hit him.
Just walk out the front door run. Yeah,
but what if he drove?
I had that problem with that meth
head check a couple of weeks ago.
Did you drive?
If she drove you got a problem.
Well then even then you just get an Uber.
You live in the new world.
It's a new world gym flooring.
You don't have to worry about that.
Worry about that crap.
Well,
he would just meet them for a drink and
then he figured if it was going to work,
hey, let's go back always by his,
his house close by within a mile.
Hey, let's go back to my place while
another one. But if he goes to his place,
then he's got to get them out.
He gets a day,
always want to leave right afterwards.
They don't want to stay. Yes. That's
hilarious. I know. So there's just
different, she had a different animal,
different animal than a woman is trying
to carve out a relationship like this is
maybe Jim Florentine is the one.
Maybe I could settle down with Jim
Florentine and have some babies instead of
that. She's like, nope,
nope. I just want some Dick.
I'm 50 I just want someone to fuck me in
my mouth and then get out of the house.
Pretty much. My nephew and my
nephew just moved to Florida.
He's a 27 I made, he is cleaning up down
there cause he used to live. I said,
oh you got to put up like Coors field
numbers. You know what I mean? Like,
of course, field a baseball,
a boy, the boy, you know,
because of the quality at a
balls just fly out of there.
The numbers are just skewered.
He's almost like he's on roids.
I write people up the altitude.
I sent people looking back
at your baseball card from
New Jersey to Florida and
he was definitely doing Royce,
what was going on in these years
because now I live in, in Florida. Okay.
Then he wasn't doing roids. Yeah.
Florida is the party state. It's insane.
It's those Florida man Twitter, uh,
notices. Have you ever seen those? No.
But Burke Christ page. Yeah.
Burt crushed from Florida.
But Florida man is a page on Twitter.
And if you go to Florida, man, uh,
on the Twitter feed,
it's all new stories about a guy from
Florida doing something retarded. It's,
they're just, it's a different
part of the world, man.
It's completely different
part of the world.
So if you're a guy who looks like a
bloated Tony Danza bloated Tony Danza just
cleaning up on the girls who've made
these terrible mistakes into the decades
pass and now they're just kind
of like settled in, settled in,
settled in their ways but still get horny
in my twenties I moved down there
because I want it to get laid. Wow.
You moved down there specifically because
he wanted to get light moved down and
high school.
Our family moved down.
I lived there for two years and I met a
couple of friends and then a couple of
years later I went down there just to
visit him and I bang like three chicks in
a week and I'm like,
I didn't even have three under my belt
and my whole life and then like six
months later I go, you know what? I'm
just moving down there. I just do.
I can get laid and that's why
that was the only thing. No.
What do you think it is?
Because it's such a transient state cause
that's a big part of what Florida is
like people from the east coast,
it just moved down there. Yeah.
Cause you always get that. You get them
in that wild phase for a couple of years.
Right. Just go, I'm, I want
to get away from my family.
I just want to go have fun and
I want to try it down here.
So you get those girls in that phase
and then eventually I moved back to
wherever they are usually. Yeah. And a lot
of like, you know, it's a lot of white,
it's a weird stakes.
A lot of white trash and this hot chicks
in Miami to just rednecks all over.
It's a weird super weird state.
Yeah.
It's a weird state too because for the
longest time it was how immigrants coming
into the country from Cuba
and how they brought drugs in through
Miami. So south Florida was just chaos.
And then northern Florida is basically
Kentucky. Yup. You know, you're,
you're basically living in the deep,
deep South in northern Florida.
The further north you get,
the more southern United States
you actually get like Florida,
like the south of Florida. It doesn't
even seem like the south, you know,
it's more like some weird fucking
offshoot of long island. Yeah, absolutely.
Miami, Fort Lauderdale and West
Palm Beach. It's a chair. Yeah,
an island meets the
Caribbean or Long Island
meets Cuba, you know?
That's what it's like. Yeah.
It's just like this weird fucking,
just people that just had to get
the fuck out of dodge and came down.
Nobody ass fucking town to do comedy too,
but yeah,
it was just down there in
Miami. Did you stand up? Yeah.
Where were you working at this place
called the home field comedy club.
I guess it used to be an
Improv. It's in Kendall. Oh
yeah. Yeah. It was a good Rome.
I mean it's part of a sports
bar. They don't, it's not like,
but they got their own back room and
stuff where they do comedy holds like 300
people. That's cool. Yeah, it was pretty
good. What are you doing over there?
Accidental child. What? Why
my child? Because you're
playing with your phone. What?
We're doing a podcast.
I'm sorry.
Spell it out now.
It's just putting in Wednesday show at
the comedy store in my calendar. Oh,
thank you. Um, do you like, do you
still go back to, uh, where you grew up?
Do you do any standup where you, uh,
where'd you grow up? I grew up in Jersey.
Do you do stand up like near the
area where you grew up? Distress.
You know what a stress factor in
New Brunswick. It's a comedy club.
That's kind of where I started
it. That's a great spot. Yeah.
New Brunswick's great too
because it's a cool town.
Cool town right next to Rutgers.
You know,
I just filmed a comedy special air a few
months back at winii brands please. Oh,
George Street playhouse. It's a theater
off for like a 400 seat theater. Oh, cool.
I just did it there. That's
a good place to do it. Yeah.
I couldn't do it at Vinnie's place.
It was to me.
I didn't want the comedy club field. I
want to more like a theater field for it.
Yeah.
I started doing my last one I did in a
comedy club and I think I'm going to do
them in the comedy club from now on.
I think that doing them in the theater,
you just don't, you lose, you
lose something and then a large,
large stage and I feel like
people at home, you're watching,
you're in the living room, you know
it's an intimate spot like you, you,
I think you could relate more to someone
on stage in front of like a couple
hundred people. Then you
know, maybe a thousand or so.
I think that the model was to get it
sold to a Netflix or showtime and Hbo.
They want it to look big,
but now you can do it all on your own.
It doesn't matter as long as it's good.
I don't think it matters.
I'm also thinking from now on,
but it doesn't matter about
like edits and shit like that.
I think you should have one camera,
one camera that's like the center of the
room above the crowd catches like the
first couple rows of the crowd in you
and that's it. Nothing moving around.
Just one clear shot of what you're doing.
Just like watching it in a comedy club
because I think that all is like cutting
it from the side and all this fancy
shit they're doing with editing.
It doesn't exist.
When you go to see a comedy show and
when you go to see a comedy show,
like it's the funniest thing you've ever
seen in your life as a comic onstage
killing in a comedy club.
You're in the back of the room and he
just watching and laughing and you're just
looking right at it. There's no
crazy angles. There's no weird cuts.
There's no shot to the audience laughing.
All that stuff's unnatural. Yeah.
Yeah. Mine, I only had
like the first two rows.
I said go to him maybe two or three
times the whole show. That's it.
I wanted a dog. Yeah, they want it to,
I'm like, I don't want, I don't need that.
If they can hear the laughs and
you know what people at home Nell,
if they want to laugh or not,
I don't need a laugh truck.
If you'd like to light up that audience,
they light up the audience.
And that's weird because everybody
gets like self conscious. Yeah.
That's always the worst. This is a weird
style that they have of doing these uh,
comedy specials.
They have this setup at the Irvine Improv.
If you'd done that place yet. The
new place. No, I haven't done that.
No one fucking amazing.
I was just there last weekend.
They have it set up for a comedy special.
So when you're in the green room,
if you're watching, you can watch on TV,
just the camera they have, you're like,
Holy Shit. That's perfect.
That's all you need.
Like the one camera they have that
catches the entire stage that you're on.
Like the camera could follow you,
they can move it a little bit if you go
left or right. And it's all you need.
It's really, it's set up perfect.
Yeah, I mean it seems like, you know,
the comedy specials used to cost
like a quarter million to shoot.
That was basically the number
you needed to raise or whatever.
Now you can do it for fucking 15 grand,
10 grand. And I look in, look amazing.
It's in the last like three or four years.
What changed?
Did the cameras and just, you know,
you don't have to run out the,
the biggest theater or somewhere,
the well turn or wherever,
you know where it's going to cost a ton
of money and hire a real big crow and
all that stuff and have seven different
cameras. I think you could do it.
Everything's getting cheaper and cheaper.
Yeah. Hinchcliffe did his entire show.
They did it with one shot.
One camera follows him into the club,
falls and onstage pans,
pans of him on stage.
Just the whole thing was
shot with one camera.
Do you remember when I used to go on the
road with you and I would have the two
cameras on the sides and one camera in
the middle and then I would just have a
camera that would walk around and
do zoom ins and that right there,
it was a whole special, a comedy
special. That's all you need really.
I think they over engineer those
fucking things. They really do.
They will have a boom mics.
I've seen people that boom,
they scan the entire crowd and
get up to the stage like, well,
what are you doing that just takes away
from what this guy's talking about?
Yeah.
Yeah. Next one I'm going to do on
a comedy club. I want to, yeah,
a small little theater like you know,
little space maybe in New York, 200 seats,
something like that. Yeah.
I think that's the future.
Like Louis C K did his thing at the
comedy store. He did his last one, uh,
in the main room. That was great. That's
kind of a big room to the main rooms.
Kind of big because it's
got like a high ceiling.
That's a very unusual club
in the sense that it's,
it seems a lot bigger than it really
is. It's only like 300 people, right?
Yeah. 300, three 50 I think
if they pack it in there,
but it seems less intimate than a
lot of rooms that are that size.
Like there's a lot of comedy clubs that
have 300 people that seem like way more
packed in.
That's such an old school show room,
you know with the big giant stage and
everything. The lights. Yeah, that's a,
that's like as old school as
it gets that place. But yeah,
the those doing those, like you, you
feel like you're there, you know,
doing something at the store or
doing something in the ice house,
you feel like you're there.
If you're watching the guy on
stage and Madison Square Garden,
if you know you can enjoy
it but you don't really,
I don't think he ever really
feel like you're there.
I think Kevin Hart's going to do,
he's doing a,
I have financial is where the eagles
play a stadium. She's Christ and I think
that's going to be us next special.
Oh isn't he doing like sixty thousand
sixty thousand people? That's insane.
Well he has a crazy show though.
He doesn't do just stand up.
He has like explosions.
He has pyrotechnics.
Like he hits punchlines and the
fire goes off behind him and shit.
He has a like a screen
that changes behind him.
Like he'll start talking about a place
where he was at and then they'll see the
screen behind him will be
of that place. Really? Yeah.
It's a pretty sophisticated set up.
Apparently he has like a
whole like group of employees.
They like our road team
that have to set up a stage.
Like that's not a small production,
that's a fucking major league
production when he's doing so.
He's like the kiss of a yeah,
for sure. Well he is definitely,
no one has ever sold more tickets
than that guy. No. In comedy,
that guy sold out the
Boston Garden two nights,
two shows in a Sunday night on a
Sunday night. I believe it was Sunday,
I'm pretty sure. But either way, two
shows in a night at the Boston Garden.
That's fucking crazy. That's like,
that's like 30,000 people. I mean,
I've never heard of anybody doing that.
He's probably used to be probably it
was dice and then it was Dane Cook and I
think Kevin Hart has eclipsed pulled of
them 60,000 people at financial field.
But I heard that Larry the cable guy does
numbers like that in the south that he
did a Josh Wolfe opened up for him.
It took a photo of the audience who was
at a football stadium and Josh Wolf's
onstage and he's taking a Selfie of
this 50,000 fucking people behind them.
It's nuts. He said that, uh, he'll,
he'll do like football stadiums. Yeah,
I could see that. Yeah.
I mean he was like, uh,
I guess right before Dana
and them and Dan came,
it kind of took the torch
from him. Bob, I mean, um,
and then Ross Russell as
another Russell Peters,
he kills it outside of the country.
But I don't think there's a place
in America where you could do that.
It's like 50,000. He's does twine like
he's done Barclay Center in Brooklyn.
He sold that out 20,000. He's done the
garden before but not, he can't do it.
I don't know if he does two or three
nights, but he's selling a lot of tickets.
Disease did two shows at
the garden in one night.
The garden is such a crazy
place for standup because
you think about the garden,
you think about like great heavyweight
title fights and Shit like that.
You know someone to be on
stage the garden telling jokes.
Billy Joel's got the craziest Gig.
He goes to the garden once a month,
once a month. That's what he does.
Drives in, probably drives a motorcycle.
That crazy fuck. Drive down to the garden,
gets onstage, kills it. Has All these,
the all the old women that your friend
flux in Florida, they all fly up for that.
A little late. I, they're probably
going off over themselves.
What are you doing over there Brian?
How can we not?
I was trying to think of Steve Martin
didn't, he used to sell out like arenas.
He did big places for sure. I just,
before he quit, before he quit,
he did some large places,
but he had that point.
We've talked about this a bunch of times
on the podcast where he hit that point
where he didn't know what was funny
anymore because people laughed at anything
he did. Yeah, he was Steve Martin.
You get out there and they were just
so happy to see him. They Start Patton.
Oswald has a fucking
hilarious bit about, remember I
told you about that casino I did,
north of Seattle and I got there.
It was like the most drunk audience
I've ever performed for it in my fucking
life.
I mean,
never had more people hackle like at a
big casino and they're spending a lot of
money. It was nuts. Simply
it's called tweel lip and a,
I was in my car to you, lip to you
lip. I was in my car just randomly.
Uh,
I have a Patton Oswald's new comedy
CD on my phone and so randomly it was
playing all these different things and
the thing it play, like play a song,
they don't play someone's bit.
I just put it on random and it played
Patton Oswald's bit about going to that
fucking very same casino.
I didn't even know he had a bid on it.
It's hilarious because I'm like,
this is,
this is the place I could relate on such
a level because I had fucking just work
there.
They pay a shitload of money to me.
It's ridiculous how much money they
pay. And even my, wow, this is crazy.
They didn't paint a lot of money and it's
like an hour outside of new of Seattle.
So you drive an hour from Seattle and
then you get there and once the show
starts you realize exactly why they're
paying you so much. They're like,
nobody wants to work here like this.
They have to pay you a lot of money to
get you to deal with this crowd. Maniacs,
the drunk, his fucking people I've ever
performed for, but there was great.
Just fire now. Oh yeah, a lot of
heckling. Yeah. I barely got bits out.
I think I made it.
I did an hour plus on stage,
maybe an hour and 10 a mighty
got two bits out. Maybe three,
maybe two who opened for Tony? Tony
opened. Yeah. How did he do? Did he did?
He did well, it was two one was
it Tony who was a Thompson girl?
I'm trying to not, I'm pretty
sure Tony. Yeah, he did
great. Tony's funny, you know,
he's got good jokes to Tony's. Like,
you know, he, he knows how to like,
well that's it's [inaudible] to
the heckler. Oh yeah. For sure.
If someone was hacking on,
but uh, they were good.
They were just really fucking hammered.
I just think that a,
a lot of those people that live out there,
there's not a lot to do.
They just get fucked. Oh yeah. I got
her to casino get messed up. Yeah.
That outside of Seattle area is very
different than the Seattle area.
Like people look at Washington
state, they go, oh yeah, Seattle,
well sorta go an hour outside of Seattle,
Seattle.
And you've got that place
where that Enim claw,
where they're going to get fucked
to death by the horse. Yeah.
Well they used to have no laws on
whether or not people can have sex with
animals.
So people flock to there and moved in
and it started farms and filmed them
fucking animals and having
animals. Fuck that. Like that's,
that's an hour outside of Seattle.
Don't get it twisted.
Washington state to crazy place.
It's got a lot of great spots in it,
but it's a crazy place.
But the Seattle is not representative
of Mo like California. You know,
everybody thinks that La is like
California. Okay. Good pickers field.
It's not that far away. Take a drive and
take a drive. Uh, you know, up to uh,
some of the weird fucking spot near the
mountains off the one that first time I,
even when I went to Sacramento, when
I landed at the airport, I'm like,
what the fuck? This is California.
Exactly. Go to Fontana.
They used to call it [inaudible] Tuckey
when we were doing the fear factor.
Yeah.
The dude,
I know there was a place nearby where a
meth lab blew up in this guy's backyard.
Yeah. Go ahead and fucking
meth lab in his backyard.
Normal regular everyday California
community. It's a California is,
we think of California.
Everybody immediately thinks of
like Beverly Hills Hollywood,
just traveling an hour outside
named direction. You might
as well be in Oklahoma.
You know, there's a lot of spots in
California that are fucked up. Wow.
That drive up to San Francisco where you
go through all the agricultural towns.
If you're a kid, your mom shit
you out. One of these towns,
you had to go to these local schools and
like Jesus Co rice and you know you're
just a two hour drive to la. If you
could just get a car, just get a car.
He could fucking end this nonsense.
So a moment in high school,
the moment you get some freedom,
your friend's got a fucking car
and you've got a full tank of gas.
So let's do what we going into the La.
Let's go to La.
You drive down and wish you lived here.
See how the civilized people,
no dirt roads wish you wish you
could be here. Said it's funky.
Fuck an agricultural town with right
ring Republican billboards everywhere.
Everywhere you go,
it's all these different republican
candidates for president and senator and
they're super right wing up there
and they're fighting over water now.
Okay,
now when you drive up there,
it's all these things about water rights.
Like go to this website and check
out this. We need, you know, we need,
we need to establish our water rights.
It's weird.
Almonds apparently suck up a bunch of it.
Yeah.
Can we just stop using almonds? If
we just know almonds, a no golf,
how much water would you have?
Fuck load almonds,
almonds, apparently talk tastes old. Takes
a lot of water to make an almond. Yeah.
I think it still wouldn't help though.
It would only help a little. They say,
apparently this is the worst drought that
California has ever on record and that
we're four years into this fucked up
drought that they need something like 11
trillion gallons of
water just to break even.
And the unlikelihood of that happening,
pump it out of Houston.
They were about to get flooded
tomorrow again. Yeah. Right.
If they could pump oil out of Houston one,
can they pump water because we don't use
as much oil as we use water. That's why.
Yeah,
I answered my own question.
All right.
Jim Florentine, let's
uh, wrap this podcast up.
Anything else you want to say
to people? Oh No, that's it man.
I was a pleasure donor. The podcast.
It's a pleasure having you on.
Fella said a lot of time.
It has been a long time. Uh,
Mr Jim Florentine on Twitter.
Jim florentine.com, right? Yeah.
Facebook get all that jazz. He periscope?
No, no. We'll Brian read Ben downs.
Brian Redman has had 10,000 people
watching him at once. That's great.
Since your pilot, it was life.
I, it's too much. I can't,
can't do it. Yeah, no. Yeah.
I don't know. Like I said,
I'll wait for six months.
There'll be a no one and I'll
jump on that. There will be,
or periscope will be undeniable.
Uh, it will be too late.
We'll be at the comedy
store this Wednesday night.
There's a new materials show at eight
o'clock. And then I'm doing that.
And then I'm doing the show at 10
o'clock with these two fine gentlemen.
And then, uh, this weekend, Friday
and Saturday, I'm at the belly room.
I'm in the belly room of the store with
Ian Edwards. Until then, I ride. Bye. Bye.
Okay.
Hm.